GONNA GIVE MEMBERS ANOTHER FIVE
MINUTES OR SO -- TO TO COME
TOGETHER AND THEN WE'LL START
WITH WHOEVER'S HERE I WILL ALLOW.
ALL OF YOU TO BE ABLE TO MAKE A
PRESENTATIONS AND HEAR THEM.
IN A TIMELY WAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE
.
WE'RE GOING.
TO CONVENE OUR INFORMATIONAL
HEARING TODAY'S UTILITY AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND FOR THE MEMBERS
WHO ARE HERE PRESENT A TIME BUT
WE'RE ALSO EXPECTING OTHER
MEMBERS TO JOIN US -- THIS --
HEARING WE'RE GONNA HAVE BROKEN
INTO TO A DIFFERENT -- SECTIONS
ONE A PRESENTATION ON WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS.
AND THE OTHER IS OVER SIDE AND
EVALUATION.
I'LL GO THROUGH IN IT ENTER DO
SO THE MEMBERS OF THE PANELS.
THAT WILL BE MAKING A
PRESENTATION BEFORE US -- WILL --
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S TIME AT
THE END OF THIS -- HEARING TO
ALLOW FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND I WOULD -- LIKE TO START OUT
BY JUST BASICALLY REMINDING ALL
OF US THAT IS THIS -- COMMITTEE
ADDRESSES MANY ISSUES THE MOST
CRITICAL.
ISSUE FACING THIS COMMITTEE IS
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE TAKEN THE
STEPS NECESSARY TO REDUCE THE
RISK AN OCCURRENCE OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
IGNITED BY UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE FOUNDATION THAT WORK.
THE FOUNDATION OF THAT WORK IS
EMBODIED AND THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY WHILE FAR MITIGATION
PLANS WHICH ARE.
THE FOCUS OF TODAY'S HEARING.
THE PLANS ARE NOT NEW BUT LAST
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED THE
IMPORT AND REQUIREMENTS OF THE
PLANS.
NEW PLANS WERE FILED IN FEBRUARY
IN THE CPUC PUT ALL HANDS ON
DECK.
HOW TO MOVE THOSE PLANS THROUGH
THE REVIEW PROCESS?
THIS ISN'T A ONE TIME EFFORT.
THE PLANS AND RELATED SAFETY
WORK BY CAL FIRE -- YES AND THE
CPUC AND OTHER STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE NOW IN BED IT AS
PRIORITIES AND THE STATE.
TODAY WE HAVE THE THREE LARGEST
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS BEFORE
US TO PRESENT KEY ELEMENTS OF
THEIR RESPECTIVE PLANS.
WE ALSO REALLY WANT TO HEAR
ABOUT BARRIERS TO FULL EXECUTION
OF THOSE PLANS.
AS WE ARE NOW AS WE'VE SAID AND
HEARD MANY TIMES -- IN A NEW
FRONT TIER AND DEALING WITH A
NEW SET OF EXPANDING CHALLENGES
AROUND THE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES.
OUR SECOND PANEL WILL PROVIDE A
REGULATORY PERSPECTIVE ON THE
PLANS REVIEW.
AND SO AS I INDICATED WE WILL
START OFF BY FIRST HEARING FROM.
A NUMBER OF PROFESSIONALS THAT
WILL PRESENT ON WALL FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS.
AND AS I CALL YOUR NAME PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO THE
FRONT TABLE HERE AND WE WILL
BEGIN -- IN THE ORDER OF WHICH
YOU'RE CALLED IN YOUR
PRESENTATION.
A BRAND THE AGOSTINO WHO'S THE
DIRECTOR FIRE SCIENCE AND
CLIMATE ADAPTATION SAN DIEGO GAS
AND ELECTRIC.
PHIL HARRINGTON SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON.
S. MATT SIGN.
A VICE PRESIDENT COMMUNITY WHILE
FIRE SAFETY PROGRAM PACIFIC GAS
AND ELECTRIC.
SO WE WELCOME ALL OF YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
PRESENTATION AND THEN WE'LL.
TURN TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THE
END OF YOUR PRESENTATION FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THEY MAY HAVE.
I WILL START WITH THE RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE FOR
THE CHEST.
A LITTLE CLOSER THERE WE GO TIME
TO TALK ABOUT OUR WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN -- IT'S NOT A
NEW THING AS THE CHAIR MENTIONED --
SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC --
HAS BEEN ACTIVELY -- PURSUING --
MITIGATION PLANS NOW FOR OVER A
DECADE AND IS ALREADY INVESTED
OVER ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS -- IN HARDENING THE
SYSTEM AND A LOT OF WHAT I'M
GOING -- TO SHARE WITH YOU IS
ONE THAT THE QUESTION AT THE TOP
OF THE AGENDA ARE THESE PLANS
REALLY MITIGATING THAT POTENTIAL.
FOR CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE ON THE
ANSWER FROM SAN DIEGO IS YES --
THEY ARE SINCE WE'VE IMPLEMENTED
THIS PLAN OVER A DECADE AGO WE
HAVE NOT SEEN -- IN A
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRESCOMIC
KNIGHTED BY ELECTRICAL.
EQUIPMENT ACROSS OUR REGION --
BUT WHAT THAT HASN'T STOPPED IS
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT ND WE
REALLY FOCUS IN THREE AREAS ONE
IS THE OPERATIONS IN THE
ENGINEERING OF THE SYSTEM.
ANOTHER GETS INTO OUR
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS AND
WHETHER TECHNOLOGY AND THEN WE
FOCUS VERY CLOSELY ON CUSTOMER
OUTREACH.
ON AN EDUCATION AND PART OF WHAT
I'M GOING TO SHARE WITH YOU
TODAY IS SOME OF THE NEWER
COMPONENTS IN THE EVOLUTION OF
OUR WHILE FIRE MITIGATION PLAN --
AND WHERE IT IS TODAY AND PART
OF THE FOCUS ON THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN PLAN IS REALLY GETTING
INTO FUEL MANAGEMENT -- I WILL
TOUCH ON VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
BUT THERE'S A REAL OPPORTUNITY.
FOR THE UTILITIES TO WORK WITH
THE FIRE AGENCIES WITH THE
FEDERAL AGENCIES LIKE BUREAU OF
LAND MANAGEMENT AND START USING
EASEMENTS.
AS FIRE BREAKS THIS IS SOMETHING
WE HAVEN'T.
DONE EXTENSIVELY IN THE PAST AND
WE'RE REALLY EXPANDING IT AS
PART OF THIS YEAR'S PLAN --
ANOTHER AREA THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT IS ENHANCING OUR IGNITION
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM WE'VE TRACKED --
IGNITIONS COMING FROM.
THE ELECTRIC SYSTEM BUT NOW
WE'RE TRACKING EVERY SPARK IF WE
CAN AND TRY TO UNDERSTAND AND
STUDY THIS AND REALLY START --
TO APPLY SCIENTIFIC METHODS TO
IGNITIONS COMING FROM THE SYSTEM
AND START TO IDENTIFY TRENDS --
TO FURTHER MITIGATE THOSE IN
THAT TO A KEY COMPONENT OF OUR
PLAN.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF HAS BEEN
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN USING
AS A TOOL IN SAN DIEGO NOW. FOR
ALMOST A DECADE -- AND IT
CONTINUES TO EVOLVE AND OF
COURSE OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT OF LESSONS
AS WE'VE HAD TO IMPLEMENT IT --
ON A BROADER SCALE THAN WE'VE
EVER HAD TO PREVIOUSLY -- BUT
WHAT WE'RE DOING THIS YEAR IS
WERE GOING IN AND TRYING TO ADD
ADDITIONAL EQUIPMENT.
IN PLACES WHERE IT MAKES SENSE
BASED OFF ALL OF OUR WEATHER
INFORMATION AND START TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT.
THAT IT HAS ON OUR COMMUNITIES
IF IT MAKES SENSE IN SOME CASES
IF WE PUT EQUIPMENT -- JUST TO
ISOLATE SMALLER AMOUNTS OF
CUSTOMERS THAT'S A MOVE THAT
WE'RE DOING AND IN ADDITION TO
MINIMIZING THE IMPACT IT ALSO
ENABLES US -- IN SOME CASES TO
REENERGIZE MORE QUICKLY -- AFTER
AN EVENT HAS PASSED -- SO THAT'S
A LARGE FOCUS OF OUR PLANNED
COMING INTO THIS YEAR.
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT HAS ALWAYS
BEEN -- SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN
EXTREMELY AGGRESSIVE ACT IN SAN
DIEGO. FOR OVER THE LAST DECADE
BUT WE'RE REALLY EXPANDING THAT
PROGRAM AGAIN THIS YEAR AS PART
OF OUR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
WHILE FIRE MITIGATION PLAN.
OUR INSPECTION RATE.
IS BEING DOUBLE -- SO WE WILL
GET HIGHS THROUGH OUR ENTIRE
HIGH FIRE THREAT AREAS TWICE AND
THAT WILL ALL BE -- INSPECTED.
IN ADDITION WHEN WE SEE A MAJOR
EVENT COMING.
WILL BE TARGETING THOSE WINDIEST
AREAS -- AND GOING IN AND DOING
PRE INSPECTIONS CHEST BEFORE AN
EVENT -- TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T FIND ANY -- ANY
ISSUES WITH THE VEGETATION IN
THAT AREA.
WE'RE ALSO INCREASING OUR POSTS
TRAM.
IN SOME CASES WHERE IT MAKES
SENSE UP TO EVEN TWENTY FIVE
FEET -- BUT WE'RE VERY
AGGRESSIVE WITH OUR PUBLIC POST
TRAM CLEARANCES RIGHT NOW AND
THEN THE OTHER MAJOR COMPONENT
THIS YEAR IS WERE REALLY TAKING
ALL OF THE TREES THAT WE TRACK
ALMOST HALF A MILLION.
AND CORRELATING IT TO ALL OF OUR
WEATHER INFORMATION.
BECAUSE WE KNOW NOW SOME TREES
ARE IN NGUYEN CORRIDORS AND WE
HAVE ALL THE WEATHER INFORMATION
WE HAVE ALL THIS TREE
INFORMATION.
SO IT'S A GOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO START TYING THESE TWO
TOGETHER AND MAKE SOME SMART
DECISIONS AND START TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE.
THOSE TREES WOULD BE MOST PRONE --
TO IMPACTS SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
OUR ENHANCEMENTS WITH BADGE
ANAGEMENT THIS YEAR -- ARE
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS PROGRAM AT
SDG ANY -- HAS BEEN RIGHT NOW --
OF ALL BEING VERY QUICKLY FOR
THE LAST TEN YEARS AND IT
CONTINUES TO INVOLVE OUR WEATHER
NETWORK -- CURRENTLY IS AT A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
WEATHER STATIONS ON THAT NETWORK
IS BEING REBUILT AND IT'S
EXPANDING -- DOWN INTO COASTAL
AREAS COASTAL CANYONS.
THE CAMERA NETWORK WHICH
CURRENTLY THERE'S OVER A HUNDRED
CAMERAS BEING MONITORED FROM
MOUNTAIN TOPS ACROSS THE REGION --
THAT'S BEING EXPANDED.
STILL IN CLOSE COLLABORATION
WITH CAL FIRE IN THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM ALL OF OUR TOOLS -- LIKE
THE FIRE POTENTIAL IMPACTS IN
THE SAND AND A WILDFIRE THREAD
INDEX WHICH IS BUILT WITH THE
FOR SERVICE THOSE ARE ALL BEING
AND WE'RE ADDING DATA
APPLICATIONS TO IT ADDING
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE WHERE WE
CAN WITH THIS FIRE POTENTIAL
INDEX.
AND CONTINUING TO PUSH THE
ENVELOPE ON THESE TOOLS --
MOVING FORWARD AND THEN ALSO ARE
WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION MODEL
WHICH CAN SIMULATE FIRE BEHAVIOR
WE'RE INCORPORATING OUR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT DATA INTO
THAT SYSTEM SO WE CAN ACTUALLY
DEVELOP RISK PROFILES FOR TREES.
WITHIN THE SYSTEM SAYING IF IF A
FIRE WOULD ORIGINATE FROM THIS
CLUSTER OF TREES IT WOULD END UP
BEING VERY CATASTROPHIC FOR DOWN
WIND COMMUNITY.
AND WE'RE STARTING TO TIE ALL
THESE SYSTEMS TOGETHER -- NOW
MOVING FORWARD BUT THE
INTELLIGENCE IS NOT JUST WITH
ALL THE WEATHER INFORMATION
THERE'S ALSO INTELLIGENCE ON THE
SYSTEM WITH PROTECTIVE DEVICES.
AND WE'RE INVESTING IN NOW
FALLING CONDUCTOR PROTECTION
WHERE WE HAVE SENSORS BUT IF THE
LINE BREAKS.
THE SENSORS WILL SENSE THAT
BEFORE THE LINE HITS THE GROUND.
AND TURN IT OFF THAT REQUIRES
UNINTERRUPTED VERY STABLE
COMMUNICATION ON THE SYSTEM SO
ES DE GENIE IS BUILDING A
PRIVATE LTE.
AS PART OF THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN WE THINK THAT'S
GOING TO BE.
A CRITICAL COMPONENT -- MOVING
FORWARD TO HAVE THE TYPE OF
COMMUNICATION THAT WE NEED FOR
THE GREAT OF THE FUTURE CAN YOU
JUSTIFY AN LTV IT'S A LONG TERM
EVOLUTION IT'S ACTUALLY A CELL
COMMUNICATION TERM -- WE'VE
HEARD OF FIVE G..
AS SAID TYPE OF LTE NETWORK BUT
IT'S A COMMUNICATION THAT WILL
ENABLE PROTECTIVE DEVICES ON THE
SYSTEM. TO COMMUNICATE IN REAL
TIME.
WE ONLY ASK BECAUSE OF THE TWO
HUNDRED OR SO -- LIST OF
ACRONYMS THAT ONE WEAPON OF WITH
LOU ONE THAT'S NOT ON IT YEAH
THANK YOU -- THE CUSTOMER OUT
REACH CONTINUES TO EXPAND AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WERE --
PUTTING A LOT OF EFFORT INTO --
THIS YEAR BOTH ON STATEWIDE --
CAMPAIGNS WORKING WITH
COLLEAGUES IN CALLOW WE ASK BUT
THEN LOCALLY IN SAN DIEGO DOING
DOCUMENTARIES.
THAT WILL BE AIRING ON LOCAL
TELEVISION TO HELP EDUCATE OUR
CUSTOMER BASE -- ON THE UP
COMING.
UP PUBLIC SAFETY POWER OFFICE --
OUR ENTERPRISE NOTIFICATION
SYSTEM IS BEING MODIFIED SO THAT
IT CAN HANDLE HIGHER CALL
VOLUMES AND DUE TO A TEXTING.
SO THAT WE CAN DO AUTOMATED
TEXTING WITH CUSTOMERS SO THAT
WE'RE FINDING WAYS TO EASE THE
COMMUNICATION -- WITH THOSE
CUSTOMERS WE'RE CONTINUING TO
PARTNER WITH YOU SEE ES DE ON
COMMUNICATIONS I'M NOT ONLY TO
STABILIZE THE CAMERA NETWORKS
AND THAT SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
BUT THIS ALSO BRINGS INTERNET TO
ALL OF THE BACK COUNTRY FIRE
STATIONS.
SO WE'RE STABILIZING THAT SO
THAT IT COULD WITHSTAND A
PROLONGED PS PS EVENT -- WITHOUT --
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
EVENT -- WITHOUT LOSING INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY -- TO BACK COUNTRY
FIRE STATIONS.
AND THE MORE ALSO RIGHT NOW JUST
IN THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING A
GENERATOR GRANT PROGRAM.
AND WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT HERE
IS ACTUALLY PROVIDING HAD LIKE A
BATTERY GENERATOR THAT SOLAR
POWERED THAT SOMEBODY COULD USE
TO POWER -- PIECE OF LIFE
SUPPORT EQUIPMENT SO THE EXAMPLE
I THINK IF SOMEBODY'S ON
DIALYSIS -- WE'RE STARTING THIS
GENERATOR GRANT PROGRAM THIS A
THIRD PARTY INVOLVED -- BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE WE'RE JUST
DEVELOPING THIS YEAR TAKING
LESSONS LEARNED IN LOOKING AT
HOW WE CAN IMPLEMENT THAT.
INTO OUR COMMUNITY MORE
EXTENSIVELY.
MOVING FORWARD.
AND THEN WE'VE ALSO -- INITIATE
A COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS AND
THESE ARE AREAS THAT WOULD BE
PRONE TO THESE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHOT OFFICE.
AND HOW WE HAVE IT SET UP NOW WE
WOULD BRING A GENERATOR OUT TO
THIS AREA AND KEEP A COMMUNITY
CENTER ENERGIZED WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES THERE THAT COULD
GIVE INFORMATION BUT THEN ALSO
CHARGE CELLPHONES.
WE'VE BROUGHT ICE TRUCKS WATER
TRUCKS THINGS THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE SOME RESOURCES TO THIS
COMMUNITY WE OPEN SIX OF THEM
LAST YEAR.
WAS VERY WELL RECEIVED -- WE'RE
EXPANDING THAT THIS YEAR WILL BE
UP -- TO ELEVEN BY THIS YEAR --
BUT OTHER THINGS WERE CONTINUING
TO MOVE WE DO FEEL THAT --
MICROGRAMS HAVE A PLACE IN
RESILIENCE IN THE BACK COUNTRY
OF SAN DIEGO.
SO I DRAW THE ATTENTION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL -- TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT WHICH RIGHT NOW IS
TRYING TO ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT
SOME STORAGE AND BATTERY AT SOME
SUBSTATIONS ONE OF THOSE
SUBSTATIONS AS BOULEVARD IT'S IN
A HIGH FIRE RISK AREA -- THAT WE
OPERATE -- AND RIGHT NOW WITH
WITH THIS IT'S SAYING THAT IT
DOES HAVE TO GO OUT FOR BIDS SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT A TWO TO THREE
YEAR DELAY.
BASED OFF THE PROPOSED DECISION
FROM THE P. YOU SEE RIGHT NOW.
TO GET THIS IMPLEMENTED SO WE
FEEL LIKE THIS IS A A REAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO START
MAKING.
SOME MORE PROGRESS ON RESILIENCE
OF THE BACK COUNTRY.
AND THEN THE LAST POINT THAT I
WANTED TO MAKE TODAY BEFORE
CONCLUDING IS THAT THE THE WILD
FIRE MITIGATION PLANS OF COURSE
THE PROPOSED DECISION HAS BEEN
PUT FORTH.
AND OVERALL THE DECISION IS THAT
IT HAS DECIDED TO BE FUNDED
THROUGH THE G. R. C. -- WHICH WE
THINK IS COMPLETELY APPROPRIATE
AND RIGHT NOW THAT THE G. R. C.
FOR US THE GENIE WAS DUE BY THE
END OF LAST YEAR -- SO WE ARE
RIGHT NOW SIX MONTHS.
BEHIND SCHEDULE ON THAT.
NOT THAT IS NOT IN ANY WAY SHAPE
OR FORM SLOWING DOWN OUR
PROGRESS ON OUR WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN -- BUT AT THE
SAME TIME FOR THE OVERALL
FINANCIAL HEALTH AND AND
STABILITY WE THINK TIMELY
RESPONSE TO THE G. R. C. IS
IMPORTANT.
AND EVEN MORE SO WITH THE RECENT
PASSING OF SENATE BILL --
FOURTEEN TEN WE THINK THAT RIGHT
NOW THE COMMISSION HAS THE
ABILITY TO EXTEND OUR THREE YEAR
G. R. C. TO A FOUR YEAR G. R. C..
AND WHAT THAT WOULD DO IS THAT
IF WE HAVE DELAYS LIKE THIS IT
WOULD BE LESS IMPACTFUL --
GENERAL RATE CASE THANK YOU THE
GENERAL RATE CASE BEING LATE
WOULD BE LESS IMPACTFUL -- IF WE
DID HAVE A FOUR YEAR -- GENERAL
RATE CASE CYCLE.
SO WITH THAT I WILL CONCLUDE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION AND I THINK IT'S
SAFE TO SAY THAT THERE WILL BE
ACRONYMS OF USE THAT WILL
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND.
BUT THE PUBLIC WATCHING PROBABLY
WILL NOT HAVE A CLUE SO IF YOU
CAN JUST SORT OF YOU KNOW DUMB
IT DOWN JUST A LITTLE BIT I
THINK I SHOULD SAY LIKE THAT BUT
MAKE IT MORE UNDERSTANDABLE.
FOR OTHERS WHO ARE WATCHING I
THINK THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
POINT TAKEN THANK YOU.
CHURCHILL HOLDEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS -- UNTIL HARRINGTON DOES
HE VICE PRESIDENT TRANSMISSION
DISTRIBUTION FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON -- WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY AGAIN -- WE WERE --
BEFORE -- I COMMITTEE EARLIER
LAST YEAR LATE LAST YEAR -- TALK
ABOUT A WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
PLANNING PROGRAMS -- SO THIS IS
SOMETHING OF AN UPDATE BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF NEW INFORMATION
HERE AS WELL AND OF COURSE -- AS
UTILITIES WE DO LOVE OUR ACRONYM
SO I WILL DO MY BEST -- TO TO
ELIMINATE THEM FROM THEIR
PRESENTATION BUT IF I MISS --
PLEASE LET ME KNOW.
SO WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY ARE WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS THAT AS HE IS PUT IN PLACE.
AND MAYBE TO TAKE A STEP BACK WE
WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE BACKGROUND OF SOME OF THE
PLANS HOW THEY'VE COME TO BE.
AND HOW WE'RE THINKING ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF OUR PLANS OF OVER
IMPLEMENTING RIGHT NOW.
THEY BUILD UPON -- PROGRAMS
WE'VE HAD FOR MANY YEARS --
THINGS WE'VE DONE IN RESPONSE TO
RED FLAG WARNINGS -- THIS IS --
INCIPIENT CONDITIONS OF HIGH
FIRE RISK -- WE HAVE
TRADITIONALLY HAD DESIGN
STANDARDS WERE DIFFERENT AND OUR
HIGH FAR AREAS OPERATIONAL
PRACTICES AROUND VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT -- OPERATIONS IN
TERMS OF BLOCKING A RE CLOSER TO
I BELIEVE WE'RE THE FIRST
UTILITY TO PUT THOSE IN PLACE --
MANY YEARS AGO -- SO WE HAD A
LOT OF PROGRAMS IN PLACE BUT WE
RECOGNIZE OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS -- THAT'S
NOT ENOUGH SO TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES OUR CUSTOMERS AND
OUR EMPLOYEES LIVE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES -- WE NEED TO DO
MORE AND THAT'S WHAT THE PLAN
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT TODAY
WILL BE ABOUT.
AS WE LOOK FORWARD WE BROADLY
CATEGORIZE THINGS -- ACROSS
THREE ELEMENTS -- HARDING
INFRASTRUCTURE -- BOLSTER
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS AND
ENHANCING OUR OPERATIONAL
PRACTICES WILL TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT EACH ONE OF THOSE -- AS WE
AS WE ROLL THROUGH THE
DISCUSSION HERE.
SO -- WANTING OF THESE IMPORTANT --
SIZE AND SCOPE OF OUR SYSTEMS --
WE HAVE A FIFTY THOUSAND MILE
SERVICE TERRITORY AND ABOUT A
THIRD OF THAT IS IN HIGH FIRE
RISK AREA.
SO THE SCOPE AND SCALE OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WERE ADDRESSING
IS VERY LARGE -- WE HAVE AROUND
A MILLION TREES IN OUR TRIM
INVENTORY -- FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND THOSE ARE IN HIGH FIRE
AREAS AND FRANKLY THAT NUMBER
WILL INCREASE AS WE IMPLEMENT
EVEN MORE AGGRESSIVE PROGRAMS TO
TRAIN VEGETATION.
IN THE HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS --
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A LOT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE A LOT OF AREA AND
WE'RE MOVING VERY QUICKLY -- TO
OUR PROGRAMS -- TO ADDRESS ALL
OF THAT TERRITORY.
SO ONE OF THINGS FOR US THAT IS
REALLY CRITICAL -- AND I THINK
IT'S CRITICAL FOR EVERYBODY TO
UNDERSTAND IS HOW WE APPROACH --
WHERE AND WHEN AND HOW WE INVEST
AND IMPROVE OPERATIONAL
PRACTICES -- WE DO THIS THROUGH
A RISK INFORMED ONES -- WE HAVE
EVOLVED OUR RISK MANAGEMENT ON A
RISK ASSESSMENT TECHNOLOGY WE'RE
USING MORE MORE MACHINE LEARNING
AND HOW WE DRESS AND LOOK AT OUR
CIRCUITS ARE PERFORMING.
UNDER HIGH -- IN EXTREME
CONDITIONS ALL THIS IS HELPING
TO INFORM WHERE AND WHEN AND
WHAT WE DO TO OUR SYSTEM.
IF WE THINK ABOUT A FOR OUR
SYSTEM.
MOST OF THE CONSEQUENTIAL EVENTS
THAT HAPPENED RELATIVE -- TO
IGNITIONS ARE SYSTEM OCCUR ON
THE DISTRIBUTION SIDE WE DO HAVE
SOME TRANSMISSION BUT THE BULK
OF THOSE AROUND DISTRIBUTION AS
WELL I WILL SEE A LOT OF
DISCUSSION TODAY FOCUSED ON WHAT
WE'RE DOING ON THE DISTRIBUTION
SIDE.
WE DO HAVE MANY PROGRAMS AND
MANY OF OUR PROGRAMS DO ADDRESS
TRANSMISSION AS WELL BUT IF YOU
WONDER WHY THERE'S A
DISTRIBUTION FOCUS IT'S REALLY
BASED ON A RISK INFORMED LANCE
[inaudible]
SO -- WITHIN THAT CATEGORY IS
ATION THE THREE BUCKETS
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS OPERATION
PRACTICES -- INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENT -- THERE'S ALSO TO
BROADWAY'S WE THINK ABOUT
MITIGATION TERMS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN IN TERMS
OF OPERATING PRACTICES -- AS WE
PUT TOGETHER THE WALL FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS AND SUBMITTED
OUR FIRST ONE THIS YEAR.
UNDER THE NEW FORMAT.
IT WAS A COMBINATION OF
SOMETHING WE FILED LATE LAST
YEAR -- OUR GREAT STATE CAN
RESULT SEE PLAN AND SO MANY
THINGS YOU MAY HAVE SEEN.
INTRODUCED IN WHILE FAR
MITIGATION PLAN ACTUALLY HAD
THEIR START INTEGRATES
RESILIENCY PLAN THAT WE
SUBMITTED LAST.
DECEMBER OR LAST SEPTEMBER.
THE REASON I STRESS THAT IS
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT EVEN
THOUGH THERE WAS A MITIGATION
PLAN COMING WE WANT TO GET
STARTED EARLY EVEN BEFORE WE
FATHER GREAT SAFETY RESERVE IT
PLAN WE BEGAN AGGRESSIVELY IN
INVESTING IN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
AND DOING THINGS -- EVEN MORE TO
PREVENT AND MITIGATE THE IMPACT
OF WILDFIRES.
SO SOME OF THESE ARE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT INSULATED CONDUCTORS
WE REFER TO THOSE DISCOVER
CONDUCTORS LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT
THOSE INSULATED CONDUCTORS --
OTHER MEDICATIONS LIKE COMPOSITE
POLES AND REMOVED OPERATIONAL
PRACTICES WILL TALK ABOUT MANY
THINGS WERE DOING THERE AND AND
WE REALLY ARE DOING -- MUCH MUCH
MORE IN MANY SPACES WE'RE GONNA
COME TO THAT VERY QUICKLY AND
AND HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO DRESS
SOME QUESTIONS AS IT RELATES TO
THE START WITH HARDING OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
ALREADY WE'VE INSTALLED AROUND A
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILES A WHAT WE
CALL -- INSULATED CONDUCTORS SO
AGAIN WHY DO WE COME TO THIS --
WE LOOKED AT THE CAUSES OF
IGNITIONS THAT MAY RESULT FROM
OUR SYSTEM.
AND AT LEAST HALF OF THEM RESULT
FROM CONTACT WITH OUR EQUIPMENT
AND MATTER SEARCHES --
VEGETATION BLOWING IN -- MYLAR
BALLOONS OTHER THINGS COME INTO
CONTACT WITH THE ELECTRICAL
EQUIPMENT SO THAT'S ONE SOURCE
WIRE TO WIRE CONTACT IS ANOTHER
AND THEN ACQUITTED FAILURES.
BY DRESSING COVER CONDUCTOR OR
INSULATED CONDUCTORS WE'VE
TARGET ROUGHLY 70% OF THE CAUSES
OF IGNITIONS OUR SYSTEM THIS IS
A VERY IMPACTFUL AND MEANINGFUL
CHANGE.
CRIME FOR STRUCTURE WE CAN ABOUT
THIS BOTH BY LOOKING AT THE
SOURCES OF IGNITIONS AND ALSO
BENCHMARKING NOT ONLY HERE IN
THE U. S..
BUT OVERSEAS AS WELL TO WHERE
THEY HAVE WHILE FIRE ISSUES AND
SEEING THAT THIS IS A PRACTICE
THAT CAN BE EFFECTIVE.
OTHER THINGS WERE DOING AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PLACE A SPACE.
FUSES SO ANOTHER WAY YOU CAN
LIMIT THE THREAD OF SET OF
IGNITIONS ON YOUR SYSTEM IS BY
MINIMIZING HE AMOUNT OF ENERGY
THAT'S TRANSMITTED. TO FLAMMABLE
MATERIAL WHEN SOMETHING HAPPENS
SO WE DO THIS BY SECTIONAL LIES
IN THE SYSTEM CUTTING INTO MORE
MORE SMALLER PIECES SO.
BOTH WHEN THERE'S AN EVENT ON
THE SYSTEM IT REACTS MUCH MORE
QUICKLY BUT ALSO SO THAT WHEN
THE ENERGY TRANSMITTED INTO THE
SYSTEM OR INTO THE GROUND WHEN
THERE IS AN EVENT.
THE THE ENERGY TRANSFER JUST
MUCH LOWER LOWER IGNITION THREAT --
ONE OTHER THING I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT ON THE DATA ANALYTICS
PIECE -- THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
HAS APPLICATIONS TO BOTH PUBLIC
SAFETY OUTSIDE A WILDFIRE BUT
WITHIN MODIFIERS WELL.
WE HAVE DEVELOPED ALGORITHMS
WITHIN WHAT WE CALL OUR
RELIABILITY OPERATIONS CENTER
THAT TARGET DID THE
PERTURBATIONS ON THE SYSTEM THAT
WE RECEIVE AND SEE FROM OUR
SMART METERS. TO METERS THAT
HAVE TYPICALLY BEEN USED TO
IDENTIFY -- REVENUE REQUIREMENTS
OR REVENUE -- MATTERS OVER --
DIFFERENT HOURS.
WE'RE ALSO USING THOSE TO TAKE
THE VOLTAGE INFORMATION TO COME
FROM THOSE.
AND IDENTIFY WHEN THERE'S A
SITUATION GOING ON OUR SYSTEM
AND TAKING PROACTIVE -- STEPS TO
DE ENERGIZED AT SO -- WE
RECENTLY ESTIMATED THATTO E.
I'D ACTUALLY WERE FINALISTS TO
FIND THEIR COMPETITION FOR AN
EDISON AWARDS SO THIS IS A
GROUNDBREAKING TECHNOLOGY THAT
WE'RE BRINGING. TO WILDFIRE IN
PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO SITUATIONAL AWARENESS -- THIS
IS SOMETHING WERE ALSO VERY
AGGRESSIVELY MOVING FORWARD AND
BOTH WEATHER STATIONS.
HIGH DEFINITION CAMERAS AND
OVERALL PRACTICES AND USE OF
DATA WE'VE INVESTED INTO SUPER
COMPUTERS TO HELP US WITH
COMPLEX WHETHER ANALYTICS -- IN
TERMS OF CAMERAS -- WE ALREADY
EXPECT TO HAVE AROUND 90%
COVERAGE OF A HIGH FIRE RISK
AREAS BY THE END OF THIS YEAR
THAT'S A TOTAL A HUNDRED SIXTY
CAMERAS.
NOW WE HAVE AROUND 6% COVERAGE
WITH OVER A HUNDRED CAMERAS ON
OUR TERRITORY.
REMEMBER THE SCOPE AND SCALE OF
OUR OF OUR SERVICE TERRITORY IS
EXTREMELY LARGE. 35% OF THAT IS
THE FIFTY THOUSAND SQUARE MILES
IS HIGH FIRE RISK AREA THESE ARE
THE TERRITORIES WERE TARGETING
WITH THE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT -- WEATHER STATIONS --
BY THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY WE
EXPECT TO HAVE AROUND EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY OF THESE DEPLOYED --
WE ALREADY HAVE OVER TWO HUNDRED
DEPLOYED AND WE'RE TARGETING
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY BY.
TWENTY NINETY THESE ARE
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL BECAUSE NOT
ONLY DO THEY PROVIDE PROVIDE
GROUND LEVEL INFORMATION ON
WHAT'S GOING ON ARE CIRCUITS
THAT WILL HELP US.
MAKE DECISIONS AROUND PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF.
THEY ALSO HELP US WITH WEATHER
MONITORING BECAUSE WE NOW HAVE
EVEN MORE GRANULAR INFORMATION
ON WHAT'S GOING ON IN A VERY
MICRO LOCATIONS ACROSS OUR
SYSTEM SO THIS IS.
THIS IS A REAL GAME CHANGER
FORCE.
WE MOVED OPERATIONAL PRACTICES
AND THERE'S A COUPLE OF
DIMENSIONS HERE THAT I REALLY
WANT TO POINT OUT. ONE OF THE
THINGS WE OBSERVED -- AND WE
HAVE HISTORICALLY -- FOCUSED
MUCH OF OUR ATTENTION ON
COMPLIANCE AND WE'VE DONE A VERY
GOOD JOB COMPLIANCE OVER THE
YEARS -- THAT'S BEEN A STANDARD
THAT I THINK IT'S HELPED US WE
HAVE USE RISK INFORMATION TO
HELP GUIDE US THERE.
BUT WHAT WE'RE SHIFTING TO NOW
IS A PREDOMINATELY A RISK INFORM
WAY OF LOOKING AT OUR CIRCUITRY.
WHAT THIS LED US TO CONCLUDE
THIS YEAR WAS THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO GO INTO ANOTHER FIRE SEASON
WITHOUT HAVING EYES ON EVERY
SQUARE MILE OR EVERY MILE?
OF OUR CIRCUITRY SO WITH THAT IN
THE END OF DECEMBER WE LAUNCH
ENHANCE OVERHEAD INSPECTION
PROGRAM WE LOOKED AT AND THIS
WAS BY QUALIFIED ELECTRICAL
WORKERS.
LINEMAN TROUBLE MAN PEOPLE WHO
DO THIS FOR A LIVING AND
UNDERSTAND HOW THE SYSTEM TO
WORK.
THEY INSPECTED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND STRUCTURES AND WE
BROUGHT TECHNOLOGY TO BEAR AS
WELL WITH THE PORTABLE DEVICES
THAT THEY COULD LOG INSPECTED
TAKE PHOTOGRAPHS OF INFORMATION
ON OUR EVEN MOVING MORE
AGGRESSIVELY.
WITH AERIAL PHOTOGRAPHY WERE
USING HELICOPTERS AND DRONES
TODAY HIGH DEFINITION IMAGES
INFRARED CAMERA SCANS SOMETHING
CALLED CORONA IMAGES ALLOW YOU
TO SEE FAULTS -- LIKE DETECTING
ARRANGING TO HELP US IDENTIFY
VEGETATION ENCROACHMENTS ANOTHER
DEFECTS OUR SYSTEM ALL THIS IS
BEING ANALYZED ANALYSED BY
QUALIFIED INSPECTORS AND ALSO
WERE USING DIGITAL -- TECHNIQUES
TO HELP US WE NEED MORE
INFORMATION FROM WHAT WE'RE
FINDING ON INSPECTIONS.
ALSO IN THE VEGETATION SPACE IN
OPERATION PRACTICES BOB I'M NOT
GONNA SPEND A LOT OF TIME HERE
THIS IS HISTORICALLY BEEN A
PLACE OF GREAT EMPHASIS FOR US.
BUT ALSO POINT OUT WE'RE MOVING
FURTHER AWAY FROM OUR TRIMS OWNS
WITH HISTORICALLY DONE DOUBLING
THAT RANGE THIS WILL ADD MORE
TREES INTO THAT -- INVENTORY ARE
ALSO LOOKING AT SOMETHING WE
CALLED HAZARD TREES THESE ARE
TREES OUTSIDE TYPICAL RIGHT AWAY
HE'S.
THAT MIGHT OTHERWISE HAVE
ESCAPED I'LL CALL IT THE THE
CHAINSAW.
BUT WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE IS TREES
THAT MAY ULTIMATELY CAUSE A
PROBLEM BLOW INTO OUR SYSTEM
FOLLOWING YOUR SYSTEM AND CAUSE
A RISK FOR US.
STORE MOVING BEYOND TRADITIONAL
COMPLIANCE TRIMMING AND
COMPLIANCE PROGRAMS EVEN MORE
BROADLY TO THINGS THAT ARE
OUTSIDE THE TRADITIONAL RIGHT
AWAY IMPACTS SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE FEELS CRITICAL
AND IMPORTANT. TO REDUCING RISK
AND AS PART OF OUR OPERATIONAL
PROGRAM [inaudible]
SO.
MOVING NOW TO US SOMETHING I
KNOW -- IT IS -- RIGHTLY GETTING
A LOT OF ATTENTION AS PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF -- MANY OF
HIS PROGRAMS WE HAVE IN PLACE OR
PROGRAMS THAT WE ARE DOING IN
THIS SPACE VERY SIMILAR SAN
DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC.
WE HAVE BENCHMARKED ACROSS
UTILITIES INTO WHO'S DOING WHAT
AND HOW WE CAN DO THIS BEST --
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THIS IS A KEY
PART OF WHAT WE ARE VIEWING AS
EXTREME EVENT -- ACTIONS THAT WE
MAY NEED TO TAKE IN THE EVENT
THAT THE WEATHER IS EXTREME AND
WE ARE MAKING DECISIONS AROUND
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE DECIDED THIS IS REALLY THE
BEST BEST OPTION FOR PROTECTING
OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
CUSTOMERS -- THIS HAS BEEN PART
OF OUR I'LL CALL IT -- TOOL KIT
FOR RISK MITIGATION FOR A COUPLE
OF YEARS NOW WE ACTUALLY DID THE
FIRST ONE OF THESE BELIEVES IN
200-032-0004 -- BUT WE
SIGNIFICANTLY UPGRADED POWER
APPROACHING IT'S OUR LOOKING AT
IT ONE OF THINGS IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT FROM HOW WE'VE DONE
THESE HISTORICALLY -- WE NOW
LOOK AT EACH INDIVIDUAL CIRCUIT
I MENTIONED DATA ANALYTICS SO
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE LOOKED
AT OUR CIRCUITS BEHAVE IN HIGH
WIND CONDITIONS.
AND SO FOR EACH CIRCUIT WE HAVE
A BUT UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
HAPPENED TO THAT CIRCUIT IN HIGH
WIND CONDITIONS.
THAT'S ONE OF THE DRIVERS WILL
ENABLE US TO SAY WHEN WE SHOULD
BE CONSIDERING.
THE ENERGIZING CIRCUIT UNDER
EXTREME CONDITIONS -- WE'VE GONE
THROUGH A NUMBER OF UPGRADES TO
OUR PROGRAM WE TO HAVE INVESTED
IN A NEW -- SYSTEM FOR CUSTOMER
NOTIFICATIONS THAT CAN PUT OUT --
NORMS AMOUNTS OF NOTIFICATIONS
IN A VERY SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME
TO GET THE WORD OUT VERY QUICKLY --
WE'VE ENGAGED AND DOZENS OF
COMMUNITY HEARINGS OF THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT TO EDUCATE
OUR COMMUNITIES ABOUT WHAT
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHOTS CAN
MEAN TO THEM -- WE HAVE ENGAGED
VERY VERY -- EARLY ON AND
REGULARLY WHEN OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS THERE ARE KEY INPUT
BOS INFORMING THE PROGRAM AND
ALSO DEVELOPING.
RELATIONSHIPS THAT WE WILL NEED
TO EXERCISE WHEN WE'RE ANY OF
THAT THIS PROGRAM WILL RELY ON
INFORMATION FROM OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS ON THE GROUND DURING
THE EVENT.
IS NOT A DECISION THAT -- WE
INTEND TO MAKE IT ISOLATION WE
LOOK TO OUR ARE -- PARTNERS OF
THE COMMISSION AND A CD AND
OTHER AREAS IS AN ONGOING
PROCEEDING THE HELP CONSTRUCT A
FRAMEWORK AROUND THIS THAT WE
CAN OPERATE WITHIN. TO MAKE THE
VERY TOUGH CHOICES I THINK
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS AS
UTILITIES WE EXIST TO SUPPLY
POWER THAT'S OUR THAT'S OUR REAL
REASON TO BE SUPPLY RELIABLE
AFFORDABLE AND SAFE POWER TO OUR
CUSTOMERS.
AND SO DE ENERGIZING A CIRCUIT --
IS NOT SOMETHING WE TAKE LIGHTLY
AND THIS IS SOMETHING WE
BUILDING UP PROGRAMS AND DATA
INFORMATION AS WE CAN MAKE THE
BEST POSSIBLE DECISION.
IN A VERY VERY COMPRESSED TIME
SITUATION [inaudible]
SO. ONE WHO ARE NEAR CLOSE TO
JUST HAVE A COUPLE MORE POINTS
TO MAKE HERE BEFORE UP MOVING ON
AT ITS CORE THIS IS ABOUT PEOPLE
AND AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING.
IS THE ORGANIZATION S. C. E.
WELL TWELVE THOUSAND OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKING WHILE FAR
MITIGATION OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY.
WE HAVE MOBILIZED EVERYBODY
ESSENTIALLY THE COMPANY HAS SOME
ROLE IN THIS WERE SUPPORTING
SOMEONE EITHER BY DIRECTLY OR
BACK FILLING FOR WORK THAT HAS
BEEN -- CREATED BY DIVERTING
RESOURCES INTO THE WHILE FAR
MITIGATION PLAN -- WE ARE
LOOKING FOR THINK ABOUT THINGS
DIFFERENTLY WERE CHALLENGING OUR
PLAYERS ARE TEAMS TO LOOK AT
THINGS IN NEW AND DIFFERENT WAYS --
WE'VE PARTNERED WITH OUR OUR
IBEW LOCAL -- FORTY SEVEN TEAM
SAVE A BIT A BILL TO HELP IN
HELPING US UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
CAPABILITIES ARE CREWS ARE.
AND AND BY THE WAY THIS GETS ON
WELL BEYOND JUST CREWS IN THE
FIELD BUILDING AND INSPECTING
THINGS THIS IS ALSO ENGINEERS
AND PLANNERS.
AND RISK -- RISK EXPERTS AND
EXPERTISE ACROSS THE COMPLEX
IT'S HELPING US TO COME TO SOME
INFORMED AND I'D SAY --
GROUNDBREAKING DECISIONS IN THIS
SPACE [inaudible]
SO.
LOU MAYBE TO CLOSE WHICH IS A
COUPLE POINTS HERE. ONE ARE WHAT
FOR MITIGATION PLANS THIS IS --
I WE HAVE A TIME LINE HERE --
WE'VE FOCUSED MUCH EFFORT ON
THINGS WE CAN DO IMMEDIATELY
THIS GETS TO EFFECTIVENESS --
THE ENHANCED OVERHEAD
INSPECTIONS WE CAN DO THAT RIGHT
AWAY WE'VE DONE THAT TO REDUCE
RISK.
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
PROGRAM WE HAVE REVISED OUR
PROTOCOL AND HAVE DRILLED ARE
TEAMS THAT ARE AYE ANTES ARE
READY WHEN THE TIME IS COMING.
TO DO THIS AND AN EVEN MORE
INFORM WHY THOSE ARE THINGS WE
DO RIGHT AWAY WE STARTED IN THE
LONGER TERM THINGS COVER
CONDUCTOR SO TAKE US SEVERAL
YEARS TO DEPLOY ENOUGH COVER
CONDUCTOR.
THAT WE THINK WILL MAKE A LARGE
DIFFERENCE WE'LL SEE BENEFITS
RIGHT AWAY WE HAVE A VERY LARGE
SYSTEM IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP
THAT IN MIND.
SOME OF THE OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS THE FUSES WILL BE
DONE WITH THAT SOON AND
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS WE MOVED
AGGRESSIVELY ON THAT SO WE'RE
ESSENTIALLY COMPLETE WITH THAT
BY -- TWENTY TWENTY WITH MOSTLY
INVESTMENT WE WILL BE DOING.
BUT WE'RE NOT GONNA STOP THERE I
THINK ONE OF THINGS THAT WE ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT -- WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS THIS RISK IS EVOLVING?
AND THE THREAT OF WILDFIRES IS
DRIVEN BY CLIMATE CHANGE AND
CLIMATE CHANGE IS NOT STABILIZE
BY ANY MEANS.
WE'RE ALSO LEARNING MORE ABOUT
DATA ANALYTICS AND TOOLS WE CAN
BRING TO BEAR TERMS OF RISK
MITIGATION.
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUALLY
INVOLVING CHALLENGE OURSELVES
WHICH WILL MEAN THIS PROGRAM
WILL CONTINUE OF ALL OF OUR TIME
THIS IS NOT A STATIC PROGRAM.
SO I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME -- TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ABOUT THIS TODAY LOOKING FOR
ANSWERS SOME QUESTIONS I ALSO
WANT TO SAY I BAG THANKS FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP.
AND THE SUPPORT AND I KNOW WILL
NEED TO WORK -- TOGETHER
COLLECTIVELY -- AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THANK YOU CAN VERY
DIFFERENT -- REGIME AND WAY OF
THINKING ABOUT OUR SYSTEM --
REALLY RESPONSE TO WELFARE
MITIGATION THANK.
THANK YOU FOR CHOOSING.
GOOD AFTERNOON GERMAN HOLDEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO BE IN FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY THANK YOU
FOR SHARED INTEREST AND A VESTED
INTEREST.
IN THE IMPORTANT.
RISKS AND ISSUES WERE ALL FACING
A RAID WILDFIRES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S NOT JUST GOING
TO BE -- THE OPERATORS -- BUT
IT'S REALLY GONNA TAKE THE
COLLECTIVE BOSS -- TO REALLY.
HELP FACE THIS UNPRECEDENTED
LEVEL OF RISK FOR OUR CUSTOMERS
OUR FRIENDS FAMILIES NEIGHBORS
AND OUR COMMUNITIES -- I'M
SUMMIT SAYING AND I AND
RESPONSIBLE FOR P. GENIES
COMMITTEE WHILE FAR SAFETY
PROGRAM.
IT IS CLEAR TO US THE
DEVASTATING TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES THAT
HAPPEN IN OUR SERVICE TERRITORY --
HAVE MADE IT OVERWHELMINGLY
CLEAR THAT MORE MUST BE DONE TO
ADDRESS THIS THREAT WITH A GREAT
SENSE OF URGENCY.
A AND P. GINNY IS TAKING
IMMEDIATE ACTIONS. TO DO THAT --
EXACTLY -- AND A LOT OF WHAT YOU
ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM MYSELF A
LOT OF PARITY -- AND
COMMONALITIES BETWEEN WHAT MY
PEERS FROM SO CAL OUT OF SAN
ANTONIO GAS ELECTRIC HAVE SHARED
AS WELL -- BEFORE I TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
SOME OF THE ELEMENTS OF OUR
WHILE FAR MITIGATION PLAN --
WANTED TO GIVE CONTEXT IN
REGARDS TO THE SCALE OF THE ARE
THE RISK IN THE ASSET BASE --
THAT WERE REALLY DEALING WITH --
WITHIN OUR SERVICE TERRITORY --
SO INCLUDED IN.
YOUR HANDOUT MATERIALS ON SLIDE --
TO WE OUTLINE.
THE OVERHEAD -- DISTRIBUTION AND
TRANSMISSION MILES THAT WE HAVE
THAT TRAVERSE EITHER ELEVATED --
OR EXTREME WILDFIRE RISK.
WE'VE GOT A TOTAL OF ABOUT
THIRTY THOUSAND MILES BETWEEN
THE TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION.
THAT TRAVERSE ELEVATED AND
EXTREME QUALIFY RISK IT'S ABOUT
A THIRD OF OUR OVER ALL ELECTRIC
OVERHEAD SYSTEM.
WHEN WE COMPARE THIS TO THE
ENTIRE ASSET BASE WITHIN?
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
NEARLY 65% OF OUR DISTRIBUTION
OVER HEADLINES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY.
THAT ARE PART OF ELEVATED IN
EXTREME WILDFIRE RISK.
AND FIX SPEND UPON THIS FURTHER --
AND LOOK AT THE NEXT PAGE.
IT REALLY PROVIDES.
INSIGHTS IN REGARDS -- TO THE
THE LAND BASE THAT'S BEEN
CHARACTERIZED AS ELEVATED AND
EXTREME OFF OUR RISK WE'VE GOT A
SERVICE TERRITORY OF SEVENTY TWO
THOUSAND SQUARE MILES MORE THAN
HALF OF THAT.
IS DESIGNATED WITHIN THOSE TWO
CLASSIFICATIONS.
THAT AMOUNTS TO ABOUT THIRTY
EIGHT THOUSAND SQUARE MILES OR
ROUGHLY 70% OF ALL OF THE HIGH
FOR AREAS WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND ONE OF THE KEY ELEMENTS SUCH
DRIVING THAT IS THE AMOUNT OF
DENSE VEGETATION -- THAT.
EXISTS WITHIN OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY -- ESPECIALLY IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY IN THE SIERRA AND THE
NORTH VALLEY -- PARTS -- OF OF
OUR TERRITORY.
SO GIVEN THAT ASSET BASED ON THE
SCALE WHAT ARE YOU DOING ABOUT
IT FROM A LOT OF FIRE SAFETY
PROGRAM.
AND THE APPROACH THAT WE'VE
TAKEN IS FROM A TIME BASED
PERSPECTIVE REALLY FOCUSED ON
THE NEAR TERM WHICH ARE THE
INITIATIVE HERE AND NOW THE MID
TERM AND THE LONG TERM SO THAT
WERE CONCURRENTLY.
IMPLEMENTING ACROSS A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH -- TO NAVIGATE
THE CHALLENGES.
REALLY THE THREE PRIMARY AREAS
AND PILLARS.
THAT ALIGN OUR THE REAL TIME
MONITORING AND INTELLIGENCE
CAPABILITIES THE NEW AND
ENHANCED SAFETY MEASURES THAT
WE'VE.
PUT FORWARD AND A CRITICAL
HARDENING OF OUR ELECTRIC SYSTEM.
I WANT TO TOUCH ON EACH OF THESE
IN A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL --
IN REGARDS TO THE REAL TIME
MONITORING INTELLIGENCE
CAPABILITIES IS VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT YOU HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUES IN REGARDS TO THE
SITUATION AWARENESS CAPABILITIES --
WE ARE DEPLOYING -- A A WEATHER
STATION NETWORK TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE SIMILAR CAPABILITIES IN
TERMS OF UNDERSTANDING THE LOCAL
CLIMATOLOGY SELECT.
THAT CAN REALLY HELP INFORM.
THE LOCAL WEATHER -- AND THE
IMPLICATIONS TO OUR ASSETS SO WE
CAN USE THAT TO INFORM ANALYTICS
TO UNDERSTAND WHERE WE HAVE.
THE GREATEST LEVEL OF RISK ON A
CIRCUIT BY CIRCUIT BASIS AND
WELL PROCEED WITH THE THE RISK
PRODUCTION MEASURE FROM A A
PREVENTION -- PERSPECTIVE --
WE'VE GOT ABOUT A PROGRAM OF
THIRTEEN HUNDRED WEATHER
STATIONS -- THAT WE'RE LOOKING
TO INSTALL BY TWENTY TWENTY OR
SOONER -- WE'VE INSTALLED NEARLY
THREE HEART AND FIFTY STATIONS
AND WE HAVE LINE OF SIGHT TO
INSTALL SIX OUR STATIONS BY THE
END OF THIS YEAR -- IN REGARDS
TO OUR HIGH DEFINITION CAMERAS
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE THE SAME
ENTITIES -- THAT -- OF THE
STRONGEST DINO FROM SAN DIEGO
GAS ELECTRIC HAD -- OUTLINED
WE'VE INSTALLED THIRTY CAMERAS --
SO FAR WE'RE LOOKING TO GET TO A
HUNDRED CAMERAS BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR -- ON OUR WAY TO GET
TO COVERAGE OF ABOUT 90% OF OUR
HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS.
WITHIN THE NEXT TWO TO THREE
YEARS -- IN ADDITION WE STOOD UP
A TWENTY FOUR SEVEN WALL FAR
SAFETY OPERATIONS CENTER WITHIN
OUR HEADQUARTERS IN SOME CISCO
TO MONITOR THE POTENTIAL LAW FAR
THREAT ACROSS OUR ENTIRE SERVICE
AREA IN REAL TIME.
AND COORDINATE PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE EFFORTS AND THIS WILL
STOOD UP.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND ALL OF
THE INFORMATION AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WERE
DEPLOYING IN REGARDS TO
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
CAPABILITIES -- WERE BRINGING
ALL OF THAT INFORMATION AND
INTELLIGENCE BACK INTO OUR WHILE
FAR SAFE SAFETY OPERATIONS
CENTER.
IN REGARDS TO OUR NEW AND
ENHANCED -- SAFETY PROGRAMS ALL
TOUCH ON A FEW ELEMENTS. ONE
ELEMENT IS REALLY AROUND OUR LAW
FOR SAFETY INSPECTIONS PROGRAM --
SO AS MISTER HERRINGTON HAD
OUTLINED -- AS WE STARTED TO
LOOK AT THE THE PRACTICES THAT
WE HAD IN PLACE BOTH FROM AN
INSPECTIONS PERSPECTIVE AS WELL
AS VEGETATION MANAGEMENT --
THEIR DOORS A RECOGNITION THAT
WE NEED TO GO WELL BEYOND THE
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS OF
REALLY LOOK AT THIS FROM A RISK
INFORMED PLANS -- AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE'VE DONE WE
LAUNCHED A AGGRESSIVE --
INSPECTION PROGRAM DECEMBER OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHERE WE MOVED
FORWARD WITH INSPECTING -- ALL
OF OUR TRANSMISSION --
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE HIGH FIRE
RISK AREAS AND WE ARE NEAR
COMPLETION OF ARE DOING THE SAME
FOR OUR DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM.
THIS REALLY -- ENTAILS A
UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL OF EFFORT W.
UNDERTAKEN -- WITHIN OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY WE'VE INCREASED THE
AMOUNT OF INSPECTIONS OF BY A
HUNDRED AND 30% FOR TRANSMISSION
AND 4100% -- BY DISTRIBUTION --
IN A VERY VERY COMPRESSED
TIMELINE -- WE'VE BROUGHT IN A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF QUALIFIED
ELECTRICAL WORKERS.
AS PART OF A CONTRACT SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO BE ABLE TO HELP AID.
A AND SUPPORT THE EXECUTION OF
THIS WORK IN A SAFE MANNER AND
WE'VE ALSO DEPLOYED -- A FLEET
OF DRONES -- TO INSPECT ALL OF
OUR TRANSMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE HI FI RISK AREAS
INCLUSIVE OF HELICOPTERS THAT
CAPTURE HIGH RESOLUTION IMAGERY --
AND WE HAVE A CENTRALIZED
INSPECTION REVIEW TEAM OF
QUALIFIED ENGINEERS AND FEEL
PERSONNEL THAT REVIEW THE HIGH
RESOLUTION IMAGERY THAT COMES IN
IN DETAIL.
PERFORM A FORENSICS TO IDENTIFY
ANY ADVERSE CONDITIONS --
PRIORITIZE CHARACTERIZE THOSE --
AND MOVE FORWARD WITH THE REPAIR
WITH A SENSE OF URGENCY.
WE ARE ALSO -- IMPLEMENTING
ADDITIONAL TECHNOLOGY WERE --
WORKING WITH THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS FROM SILICON VALLEY TO
HELP ENABLE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND MACHINE
LEARNING ON THE BACKEND.
ON SO THAT WE CAN DEVELOP THE
MACHINE LEARNING MODELS SO AS
THE IMAGERY IS CAPTURED ON A GO
FORWARD BASI WERE ABLE TO USE.
MACHINE LEARNING TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL ISSUES.
IN A MORE EFFECTIVE -- AND
REPEATABLE AND STANDARDIZED WAY --
IN REGARDS TO OUR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES.
WE'VE -- THIS YEAR DOUBLED.
THE SIZE OF OUR PROGRAM --
COMING INTO THIS YEAR -- THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
WAS UP ROUGHLY A THREE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS WE'VE ACTUALLY
MORE THAN DOUBLE THAT -- WE NOT
ONLY HAVE A FOCUS ON MAINTAINING
THE MINIMUM REQUIRED CLEARANCES
AS PRESCRIBED IN THE RESPECTIVE
COMPLIANCE REGULATIONS -- IN
ADDITION TO FOCUSING ON THE DEAD
DYING AND DISEASED TREES AS PART
OF A TREE MORTALITY PROGRAM
WE'VE ON RAMP TO RISK BASED
PROGRAM -- CALLED OUR ENHANCE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
AND THAT'S REALLY FOCUSED ON
REMOVING ALL OF THE OVERHANG --
THAT MAYBE HANGING ON TOP OF OUR
OF BARE WIRES EVEN THOUGH --
THERE'S ADEQUATE CLEARANCE -- AS
PRESCRIBED IN THE THE COMPLIANCE
REGULATIONS.
WE HAVE ALSO MOVED FORWARD WITH --
IDENTIFYING AND CHARACTERIZING
HAZARDOUS TREES AS WE LOOKED AT
THE NUMBER AND THE DRIVER OF
VEGETATION BECAUSE TECHNICIANS
WE IDENTIFIED THAT THERE IS A
STRONG CORRELATION. FOR CERTAIN
TYPE OF TREES THAT HAVE A HIGHER
PROPENSITY OF FALLING IN OR
BLOWING INTO OUR LINES THAT MAY
BE TALL ENOUGH YET NOT FAR
ENOUGH FROM OUR LINES.
ON SEWER PROACTIVELY IDENTIFYING
THOSE TYPES OF TREE SPECIES --
AND IF THEY HAVE A CERTAIN DE
FACT EVEN IF THEY'RE ALIVE AND
HEALTHY MOVING FORWARD WITHOUT
REMOVING THAT RISK.
FROM OUR SYSTEM AND ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR THE FOCUS AROUND OUR
AND HAS VISITATION MANAGEMENT
AND THE INSPECTIONS IS WHEN WE
ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE DRIVERS FOR
THE FIRE IGNITIONS WITHIN P.
GINNY SYSTEM.
OF VEGETATION MANAGEMENT OR
VEGETATION COMING IN CONTACT
WITH OUR OVERHEAD SYSTEMS MAKE
UP ABOUT 50%.
OF THE IGNITION DRIVERS AND
EQUIPMENT.
RELATED ISSUES IS ANOTHER 25% --
AND THE BALANCE OF THE 25% IS
PROBABLY AROUND THIRD PARTY --
ANIMAL CONTACT OR A ABOVE A
VEHICLE FOR EXAMPLE COMING IN
CONTACT WITH OUR SYSTEM.
ANOTHER ELEMENT VERY SIMILAR.
TO WHEN MR -- HERRINGTON OUTLINE
FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
MORE FUNDAMENTALLY REDESIGNING.
OUR ELECTRIC DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM --
AND THAT'S REALLY PART OF OUR
LONGER TERM SYSTEM HARDENING AND
PRESIDENCY STRATEGY WE'RE NOT
WAITING WE'VE -- ALREADY MOVED
TO ACTION ON THAT WE'VE GOT
ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE MILES
COMPLETED BETWEEN.
THE LAST QUARTER OF LAST YEAR AS
WELL AS THE WORK WE'VE DONE TO
THIS YEAR.
AND WE LOOK TO GET.
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILES
COMPLETED BY THE END OF THE YEAR
AND START TO MOVE TO ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED MILES.
PER YEAR BEGINNING NEXT YEAR AND
SOME OF THE EXAMPLES ON A
FUNDAMENTAL REDESIGN IS WERE --
EVALUATING -- OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO
ELIMINATE THE RISK -- BY
REMOVING THE OVERHEAD ELECTRICAL
LINES IN SOME CASES WE'VE GOT A
FIVE AND A HALF TO SIX MILE LINE
THAT'S TRAVERSING.
A HEAVY DANCE AND FOREST AREA
THIS PROVIDING SERVICE TO
RAILWAY SIGNAL -- THERE'S A
BETTER WAY TO PROVIDE SERVICE --
TO THAT -- RESPECTIVE ENTITY AN
INDIVIDUAL FROM A SOLAR AND A
BATTERY BACK UP AS AN EXAMPLE SO.
HOSPITAL OF THE NATION IS ONE
PART OF WHAT WE'RE LOOKING OUT
FOR SYSTEM HARDENING.
ANOTHER DIMENSION ABOUT SYSTEM
HARDING IS -- LOOKING AT
TARGETED UNDER GROUNDING.
SPECIFICALLY AROUND A
COMMUNITIES THAT MAY HAVE.
SIGNIFICANT ADDRESS CHALLENGES
AND WE'RE WE HAVE OUR POLL LINES --
THAT TRAVERSE.
ON OVERHEAD BASIS ALONG THOSE
EGRESS ACCESS IS THOSE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US.
TO PROACTIVELY UNDERGROUND AS
PART OF SYSTEM HARDENING -- AND
THEN THE LAST IN A KINDA ELEMENT
AROUND SYSTEM PARTING IS VERY
SIMILAR AROUND -- IMPLEMENTING
COVERED CONDUCTORS AND
TRANSITIONING AWAY FROM THE WHAT
POLLS TO MORE OF OF THE
COMPOSITE BASED POLLS.
THE LAST ITEM I'D LIKE TO TOUCH
ON IS THE PRODUCT OF THE
LEGISLATION AROUND THE PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF.
WE BENCHMARK HEAVILY AND AND
LEANED UP SIGNIFICANTLY. TO OUR
PEERS IN THE SOUTH THAT HAVE HAD
THIS PRACTICE IN PLACE FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS.
AND WE'VE UNEMPLOYED -- MANY OF
THOSE POLICIES AND PRACTICES WE
IMPLEMENTED OUR FIRST PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF PROGRAM
LAST YEAR -- THIS YEAR WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED IT TO
INCLUDE NOT JUST THE EXTREME FAR
RISK AREAS BUT ALSO THE ELEVATED
FIRE RISK AREAS -- AND WE'RE
ALSO INCLUDING A TRANSMISSION
OUR SYSTEM IN OUR RISK
EVALUATION AND DETERMINATION
FROM A PROACTIVE -- DE
RESERVATION PERSPECTIVE.
RIGHT VERY MINDFUL OF THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT THAT THIS COULD
CAUSE FROM A PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSPECTIVE WHEN WE DO DE
ENERGIZED.
US WE'VE GOT THE A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH ON MEDICATION -- AS IT
PERTAINS TO THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT GREAT BASED SOLUTIONS WERE WE
ARE PROACTIVELY IMPLEMENTING --
GENERATION -- POINTS AND BACKUP
GENERATION POINTS MOBILE
GENERATION POINTS ON A GRID
SYSTEM ITSELF TO BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN.
SOME OF THE CRITICAL ESSENTIAL
SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED WITHIN
THEIR RESPECTIVE COMMUNITY --
WE'RE DOING APALETTE CURRENTLY
WITH THE PACIFIC UNION COLLEGE
UP AND AND WHEN IN THE NAPA
COUNTY -- AND WE'RE GONNA BE
USING THAT AS A BLUEPRINT FOR
THEIR EXPAND THAT CAPABILITY
GOING FORWARD IN TERMS OF THE
GREAT BAY SOLUTION.
THE OTHER THING WE'RE DOING IS
WE ARE FURTHER SEGMENTING OUR
DISTRIBUTION -- CIRCUIT SO THAT
WE CAN BE MUCH MORE TARGETED --
INSTALLING THE WEATHER STATIONS
AT THE GRANULAR LEVEL WHEN WE DO
DE ENERGIZED SO WE'RE NOT
IMPACTING A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF CUSTOMERS.
AS A RESULT OF A DEACTIVATION OF
ACT.
THE SECOND PART OF THE STRATEGY
IS REALLY A COMMUNITY BASED
SOLUTION -- SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS WE
HAVE MORE THAN FIFTY LOCATIONS
IDENTIFIED.
NOT ACROSS THE TWENTY SEVEN
DIFFERENT COUNTIES -- AND WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WRAP THAT
UP AND ENGAGE WITH A LOCAL
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO
MOVE.
TO MORE OF A PERMANENT TYPE OF A
FACILITY IN COORDINATION IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM -- FROM A
A BACKUP GENERATION PERSPECTIVE
FOR THE COMMUNITY -- CAN
AGGREGATE WE CAN PROVIDE CHARGE
SERVICES BASIC NEEDS A NECESSITY
CENTERS WATER SERVICES AND
INFORMATION IN REGARDS TO THE
EVENT ITSELF.
AND THEN THE THE LAST ITEM THAT
WE'RE BASICALLY FOCUSED ON A IS
REALLY A CUSTOMER BASE SOLUTION
AND WE'RE REALLY ENABLING -- THE
GENERATION MARKETS WERE MAKING
IT EASIER FOR OUR RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS -- TO INTERFACE WITH
THE VENDORS THAT PROVIDE TURNKEY
SERVICES FOR BACKUP GENERATION
SO THEY CAN HAVE.
APPROPRIATE ACCESS TO ENTITIES
LIKE HOME DEPOT AND AND AND
OTHERS THAT BASICALLY INSTALLED --
THE GENERATORS AND ALSO PROVIDE
THE GENERATORS THEMSELVES NOT
MORE SPECIFICALLY IN REGARDS --
TO BE AT THE RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS AND THE THE MEDICAL
BAY FIND CUSTOMERS.
WE ARE REALLY.
LOOKING AT AND AND CURRENTLY
PARTNERING UP WITH A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION KNOWN AS THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION OF
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS --
AND LOOKING TO ESTABLISH A GRANT
BASED PROGRAM WHERE WE CAN
ALLOCATE FUNDING. TO MAKE THE
BACKUP GENERATION -- MORE COST
COMPETITIVE A MORE AFFORDABLE
AND ACCESSIBLE. FOR THOSE
CUSTOMERS.
I AND IN CONCLUSION SINCE WE
FILED THE BALL FORCE IF YOU PLAN
IN FEBRUARY.
WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDING UPDATES
TO THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITY
COMMISSION IN REGARDS TO OUR
PROGRESS -- BUT SOME OF THE THE
BARRIERS WHICH NOW I KNOW THE
OTHER COMMITTEE WAS INTERESTED --
IN IN LEARNING ABOUT WE WE HAVE --
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE -- BE A
COMPLETELY -- TURN THE THE LABOR
MARKET FOR OUR LINE CLEARANCE
QUALIFIED WORKERS IN OUR LINE
MAN -- UPSIDE DOWN GIVEN THE THE
VOLUME OF WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
WITH BROUGHT IN MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND CONTRACT RESOURCES.
WE HAVE DOUBLED THE NUMBER OF
QUALIFY TREE WORKERS THAT WE
HAVE -- THIS TIME LAST YEAR WE
HAD FIFTEEN HUNDRED WORKERS WERE
NEARLY THREE THOUSAND WORKERS --
AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES ON HOW BEST.
WE CAN BRING IN AND CONTINUE TO
BRING IN ADDITIONAL QUALIFIED
RESOURCES TO DO -- THE THE LEVEL
OF WORK THAT'S NEEDED TO REDUCE
RISK ON THE SYSTEM AND DO IT IN
A SAFE MANNER.
AND WITH THAT WILL TURN IT OVER
TO THE COMMITTEE AND CHAIRMAN
FOR YOURSELF FOR ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
WITH THANK YOU AND I DO
APPRECIATE YOU ALL BEING HERE
AND ARE GIVING US -- MORE
INTIMATE UNDERSTANDING OF THE
WALL FAR MANAGEMENT PLAN WELL
FAR MANAGEMENT PLAN THAT YOU
PRESENTED TO THE CPUC AND TO
GIVE US A CHANCE TO SORT OF ASK
QUESTIONS AND WERE YOU
PRIORITIZED.
MANY OF THESE APPROACHES I I
HAVE TWO QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO
RAISE -- JUST TO GET US STARTED --
MR HERRINGTON -- THERE ARE
REPRESENT THE AREA ABOUT TO DO
YOU KNOW WHICH IS A FOOT --
COMMUNITY.
THE BASE OF ANGELES FOREST AND
YOU TALK ABOUT THEY HAVE HAD AND
WE HAD A COMMUNITY HEARING.
OF SOME CONCERN ABOUT SORT OF
THE THE CRESTS OF THREE TRIMMING
THAT'S TAKING PLACE IN THAT AREA.
AND I GUESS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
I HAVE IS WHAT EFFORT IS --
EDISON TAKING TO SERVE DO A
BETTER JOB OF INTEGRATING WITH
THE COMMUNITY LETTING THEM KNOW
WHAT YOUR PLANS ARE.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW.
JUST KNOW THAT AN AREA OF
ALTADENA -- I HAVE ARBORS.
ISRAEL ARBORIST THAT LIVE IN
THAT AREA AND THEY WERE THE
FIRST TO CALL TO SAY.
EXCUSE ME THE DEGREE OF CUTTING
IN EXCESS OF NATURE OF THE
CUTTING OF THE TREES -- BECAUSE
GREAT ALARM TO THEM SO.
HOW DO WE START TO WORK TOGETHER
WITH THE COMMUNITY AS YOU'D?
MAYBE RIGHTFULLY LOOK AT
EXPANDING YOUR OF YOUR TRIMMING
AREA SO THAT THERE'S A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE REASONS WHY
AND THE METHOD THAT YOU'RE USING --
TO TRIM BACK THE TREES SURE BOB
THANK YOU JERROLD AYE THAT WAS A
THAT HEARING AS WELL SO I KEENLY
APPRECIATED I ALSO LIVE IN THE
AREA SO I KNOW THAT -- THE TREES
ARE BELOVED THERE AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT SO.
I I BUT YOU'VE HIGHLIGHTED A KEY
POINT FOR US I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE FOCUSED ON A
SINCE AND EVEN BEFORE THAT I
THINK PART OF THIS IS GETTING
THE WORD OUT.
OF MORE COMMUNITY HEARINGS AND
MORE COMMUNITY OUT REACH TO
EDUCATE THE COMMUNITY IN THE WHY
AND THE THE WHAT WE'RE DOING --
WE'VE ALSO REFINED I'LL CALL IT
OUR ESCALATION PROCESS OUR
PROCESS FOR NOTIFICATION AND AND
pAND AND DISCUSSION AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH -- WITH ANY KIND OF
TRIM ACTIVITY -- A COUPLE OF
POINTS I DO WANT TO SAY THAT THE
THE THE THE FOLKS FROM OUR TEAM
WHO DO THE LISTING AND
IDENTIFICATION OR ALSO QUALIFIED
ARBORIST SO -- THEY EVEN THOUGH
THEIR JOB IS TO TRIM TREES --
THEY THEY HAVE A PASSION FOR
TREES AS WELL -- BUT WE
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A SENSITIVE
ISSUE AND IT'S PART OF THE
BALANCE THAT WE ARE ARE TRYING
TO COME TO AS WE LOOK -- TO
WORKING WITH OUR COMMUNITIES --
TO TO TO HAVE THEM BRING THEM
ALONG AND FRANKLY THIS -- THIS
PROCESS WE'RE MOVING FORWARD
WITH TO REDUCE RISK BUT MORE
COMMUNITY OUTREACH WE'VE
UPGRADED OUR NOTIFICATION
PROCESS IS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND SOLICIT FEEDBACK SO WE CAN
EDUCATE THEM I I THINK PART OF
THIS -- IS IS THE FACT THAT WE
ARE DOING THINGS DIFFERENTLY AND
MORE EXTENSIVELY AND AND
CANDIDLY MORE AGGRESSIVELY
BECAUSE OF THE RISK.
I THINK THE SHARP EDGE OF THAT
IS THAT -- SOME FOLKS HAVEN'T
SEEN THAT BEFORE AND MAY NOT
UNDERSTAND THE RATIONALE FOR
DOING THAT AND THAT'S WERE
FOCUSING OUR EFFORTS.
I THINK THAT'S FAIR -- BUT I AND
I I LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW
THAT THAT IS TO IN A A MAJOR
ISSUE IN THE AREA AND I'M
ASSUMING THAT OTHER COMMUNITIES --
BORDER FOR HILL -- OR FORCED
ERRORS THE INTERFACE ARE
PROBABLY GOING TO HEAR SIMILAR
CONCERNS FROM.
OF THE OTHER -- TERRITORY
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE
DISCUSSION KIND OF THIS FOR ALL
OF YOU TO TO SORT OF THINK ABOUT
ERICA RESPOND -- TO AND THIS IS
REALLY TRYING TO UNDERSTAND --
ON THE ENERGY IS A SEND WHAT
YOUR BACKUP.
STRATEGIES ARE AS IT RELATES TO
POWER AND HOW YOU WOULD PROVIDE
THAT I KNOW STORAGE IS ONE OF
THE OPTIONS BUT CLEARLY YOU CAN
HAVE STORAGE IN EVERY.
GARAGE -- AND THEN OF COURSE AS
YOU LOOK AT MICHAEL GRADES
MICHAEL GRADES ARE CERTAINLY.
A APPROACH THAT -- HAS SOME
VIABILITY BUT UNLESS YOU'RE
UNDERGROUND IN THE LINES.
THEY WOULD BE IMPACTED BY THE
ENERGIZING AS WELL.
AND THEN OF COURSE THE ULTIMATE
COST TO THE RATE PAYERS.
HOW DO YOU KIND OF CLARIFY THESE
ISSUES AND AND HOW YOU'RE
LOOKING AT MOVING FO TO PROVIDE
A -- A STRATEGY.
FOR BACK UP WHERE APPROPRIATE --
WHEN YOU DE ENERGIZED IN CERTAIN
AREAS?
MAYBE I CAN -- BILL OFFER
COUPLE THINGS IN MY COLLEAGUES
HERE HAVE VIEWS -- AND AND WE
WITH A LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME OR
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT -- AND
IS IT IS WORKING ON THAT -- WE
DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO SHARE YET
SO.
I I IT IT PARALLELS MANY OF THE
RESPONSES AND AND AND PLANS AND
AND PROTOCOLS WERE PUTTING INTO
PLACE.
FIRST AND FOREMOST CAM THIS IS A
THIS IS A SAFETY ISSUE WHICH IS
WHY WE'RE EVEN HAVING A
CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW SO -- THE
THE DECISION TO DO IS NOT MADE
LIGHTLY SO PART OF IT I CAN ONLY
STARTS WITH HOW DO WE FIND WAYS
TO REDUCE THE OVERALL FOOTPRINT.
OF OF THE SPS A VENT AND FOR US
THAT'S DESIGNING CIRCUIT LEVEL
OF SPECIFICITY SO WE DON'T HAVE
A BLANKET LEVEL IN EACH EACH
ZONE WHERE WE DE ENERGIZED.
WE UNDERSTAND EACH INDIVIDUALS
CIRCUIT WHERE WE EXPECT TO SEE --
POTENTIAL PROBLEMS AND THAT
FORMS THE THRESHOLD SO THAT'S
ONE WAY OF MINIMIZING FOOTPRINT.
ADDITIONAL SEXUALIZED IN WHICH
MR SINGH MENTION HERE -- AGAIN
OTHER WAYS TO REDUCE THIS AND
THEN LASTLY GREATER INFORMATION
FROM THE WEATHER STATIONS FROM
OTHER PREDICTIVE CAPABILITIES TO
HELP US HONE IN ON WHEN WE
REALLY THINK WE WILL NEED TO DO
THIS.
THROUGH THE LAST LINE OF DEFENSE
FOR ONE OF THESE IS -- WE DO PRE --
PREVENT PATROLS WHICH AGAIN
IDENTIFY SHOULD WE DO WANT OTHER
PROBLEMS ON THE LINE TO MAKE US
MORE BUYS.
TWO OF THE REASONS WE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT THIS THIS HELPS US
UNDERSTAND WHEN TO DO IT AND
WHEN NOT TO DO IT.
AND ON THE GROUND RESOURCES WE
WILL HAVE PEOPLE ON THE GROUND
OVER MAKING THESE DECISIONS TO
ADVISE SO THIS IS AGAIN
MINIMIZING THE FOOTPRINT.
WHEN THEY HAPPEN -- WE DO -- IN
CASES WE LOOK TO OUR AS OUR
MERGED THE SERVICE PROVIDERS --
CERTAIN CLASSES OF CUSTOMERS
WHERE WE ENGAGE IN DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT PROVIDING BACKUP
GENERATION SO THAT'S ONE ELEMENT
OF IT -- ANOTHER ELEMENT OF IT
IS WE ALSO HAVE PILOT PROGRAMS
WERE PILING WHICH PROBABLY WITH
A HIGH SCHOOL IN SOUR JOAQUIN A
IT'S NOT -- IT'S ALMOST A MICRO
GOOD IT'S A BACK IT'S A STORAGE
CELLAR COMBINATION OF THAT WE
HAVE A RESILIENCY CENTER IF YOU
WELL.
BASED ON BATTERY TECHNOLOGIES
SOLAR TECHNOLOGY THAT COULD
WITHSTAND -- A PROLONGED PS
BECAUSE OF THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO
REPLICATE MORE OF THAT.
WE ALSO ARE USING MOBILE
TRAILERS THAT HAVE CHARGING
STATIONS THAT WE BOTH -- BOTH MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IS TO APPLY
PROVIDING PLACES TOGETHER -- I
REALLY TO POINT OUT ONE OTHER
THING IN THIS IS.
WHERE WE PARTNER WITH -- YES --
ON EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS URGENCY
SIR THANK YOU OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES GALLO YES
CALOR OFF TO MERGE THE SERVICES --
WHO WILL HELP US?
GET THE WORD OUT ABOUT COMMUNITY
RESILIENCY BECAUSE ONE OF THINGS
THAT -- WE WE OFTEN FORGET IS
THERE ARE OTHER REASONS THAT YOU
MAY LOSE POWER FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME -- CATASTROPHIC
EVENTS SUCH AS AN EARTHQUAKE --
OTHER KIND OF SYSTEM DISRUPTIONS.
SO WHAT WE WE WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EDUCATE THE
CUSTOMER THE COMMUNITY ABOUT
RESILIENCY AND BECOMING PREPARED
FOR OTHER THINGS THAT MIGHT
HAPPEN SO THERE'S MULTIPLE
PRONGS TO THIS.
ABOUT HIS CLOTHES WITH THIS IS
ALSO SOMETHING WERE INVOLVING --
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT AND MAYBE
THE LAST THING I'LL SAY IS
ULTIMATELY THE SYSTEM HARDING
THAT WE DO.
WILL BRIDGES TO A TIME WHEN
THESE ARE LESS AND LESS LIKELY
THE MORE YOUR SYSTEM'S HARDENED
AND IS LESS LIKELY TO BE --
IMPACTED BY CONDITIONS WHICH
CAUSES TO DO PS PS THE LOTS OF
THESE WILL HAVE MET PROBABLY IN
THE SHRINKING THE FOOTPRINT.
THE THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD
TO THAT -- IN THAT -- COVERED
WALLS -- FILL FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
THE OTHER AVENUE FROM A
EDUCATION AWARENESS PERSPECTIVE
IS OF THE LAW THE CRITICAL
ESSENTIAL CUSTOMERS SO AND
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED TO
THE COMMUNITY IN TERMS OF
HOSPITALS.
FROM THE WATER AGENCIES WASTE
WATER AGENCIES -- FROM EDUCATION
AND AND PREPAREDNESS PERSPECTIVE
THAT THERE CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS
THAT REQUIRE THEM TO ALSO HAVE
BACKUP GENERATION SO.
YOU KNOW HAVING THAT HEIGHTENED
AWARENESS -- THAT THIS IS A
REALITY -- GIVEN THE EXTREME
NATURE OF THE WILD FIRE RISK ON
THE CLIMATE CHANGE.
THAT WE'RE FACING WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- KIND OF A
BRIDGE SOLUTION IF YOU WANT TO
CALL IT RIGHT IN TERMS OF THE
PROACTIVE THE LEGISLATION.
IS SOMETHING WE DON'T
NECESSARILY SEE THAT COMPLETELY
GOES AWAY BUT THE LIKELIHOOD OF
EXERCISING IT.
REDUCES AS WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
IN REGARDS TO THE IN HAS
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS
THE SYSTEM HARD BANG -- WERE
ALSO -- PILOTING -- INTENTIONAL
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S AFTER COMING
OUT OF THE STATE OF VICTORIA IN
AUSTRALIA.
THAT HAS HAD SOME VERY SIMILAR
ISSUES CALLED -- THE RAPID EARTH
FAULT CURRENT LIMITER AND REALLY
THE UNDERLYING PREMISE OF THAT.
TECHNOLOGY IS TO BE ABLE TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF ENERGY.
THAT FLOWS THROUGH THE THE
ACTUAL -- THE CONDUCTOR OR BARE
WIRE -- AND WHEN IT DOES SUFFER --
IT ACTUALLY -- REDUCES THE
AMOUNT OF ENERGY TO THE POINT
WHERE IT DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH
ENERGY TO CREATE A FIRE IGNITION
EVENT -- AND THEY'VE ACTUALLY
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED IT --
AND PROVEN IT -- IN SUCH A
BECOME PART OF THEIR LEGISLATIVE
REQUIREMENT WITHIN THE STATE OF
VICTORIA -- AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT -- WE'RE CURRENTLY PILOTING
AND UP LOOKING TO ACTIVELY
PURSUE AS WELL.
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN SAN DIEGO
IN ADDITION TO THIS SUCH AS AS
COVERED IT REALLY WELL I DON'T
THINK WE FOUND THE SAME SOLUTION
IT'S IT'S ALMOST THERE'S BEEN
UNIQUE.
IMPLEMENTATIONS OF THIS KIND OF
MITIGATION STRATEGY FOR
DIFFERENT SOLUTION SOME EXAMPLES
ONE OF OUR TRIBAL NATIONS YOU
KNOW WE'VE WORKED WITH THEM THEY
SAID WE REALLY NEED.
THIS AREA TO REMAIN ENERGIZED SO
WE WORKED WITH THE TRIBE IN WHEN
AND CLEARED ALL THE VEGETATION
UNDER PARTICULAR LINES WE
STATION A CONTRACT FIREFIGHTING
RESOURCES THERE AND WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO SERVE THAT -- COMMUNITY
THAT WAY ANOTHER ONE WE'RE
LOOKING AT YOU KNOW MORE THE
TRADITIONAL CAN WE PUT A BATTERY
WALL AND SOLAR PANELS AT THOSE
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS AND
KEEP THOSE GOING.
THERE ARE SOME OTHER PLACES
WHERE IT MAKES SENSE FOR US TO
DO SOME SHORT SPANS OF STRATEGIC
UNDERGROUND ACT.
AND THAT MIGHT BE ABLE TO ENABLE
US TO KEEP A DOWNTOWN AREA
ENERGIZED BUT I THE POINT BEING
IS THAT A LOT OF WHAT WE FOUND
IS THAT.
WHAT WORKS FOR ONE COMMUNITY
MIGHT BE A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN
ANOTHER BUT WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY WE CAN WORK TOWARDS
THESE SOLUTIONS AND IT IT DOES
BECOME A COMMUNITY?
BASED SOLUTION.
I APPRECIATE THAT [inaudible]
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
TODAY.
I REMEMBER YOUR JOBS I WANNA BE
MINE EITHER AND FOR YEARS --
KIND OF THREE GENERAL QUESTIONS
IN A AND I THINK YOU'VE YOU'VE
SOMEWHAT ADDRESS THEM IN THE
ISSUE OF DECREASING POWER
SHUTTING IT DOWN.
IS MICROBE GRADES A BETTER WAY
TO GO WITH BACKUP BATTERY AND DO
WE HAVE THE CAPACITY TO KIND OF
PATCHWORK AROUND THE STATE.
SOME PLACES THAT ARE MIGRATED
WERE AND THEN BE ABLE TO GET THE
SYSTEM BACK UP IN A TIMELY
FASHION BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
ALWAYS BEEN THE CONCERN.
UP.
HERE THE QUESTIONS AROUND.
THE COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS OF
HARDENING ALL THE LINES VERSES
UNDER GROUNDING EVERYTHING
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT UNDER
GRANTING I KNOW THERE'S SOME
THINGS ARE COST PROHIBITIVE BUT
IS THAT ALSO LIKE YOU'VE SAID.
IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE
THERE'S GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
[inaudible]
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS.
AND THEN AS WE'RE STILL GOING TO
THE NINE A ONE PROCESS AT ALL OF
THAT IS COMING IN.
THE PLANS ARE COMING IN.
YOU KNOW WHAT IF WHAT IF
DIFFERENT.
THINGS ARE FOUND AFTER NINE A
ONE AND THEN WHAT WILL BE YOUR
UPDATING PROCESS AS WE GO
FORWARD WITH THAT.
DO YOU WANT TO START GRABBED THE
GO AHEAD OKAY.
IT WOULDN'T WHEN WE LOOK AT
LARGE SCALE DEPLOYMENT OF
MICROGRAMS WE WE HAVE ULTIMATELY
LOOKED AT THOSE AS A TOOL FOR
FOR RESILIENCE -- BUT IT'S NOT
SOMETHING RIGHT NOW THAT IS
BEING.
DEPLOYED ON A ON A WIDE SCALE --
TYPE OF FEATURE ACROSS SAN DIEGO
WE FIND MORE RIGHT NOW IT'S BY A
PARTICULAR RESIDENTS WERE
LOOKING AT IT AND WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND ITS PLACE IN THE
RESILIENCE PORTFOLIO BUT RIGHT
NOW IT'S NOT.
GOING INTO A LARGE SCALE --
DEPLOYMENT.
IN TERMS BECAUSE IT JUST COST OR
PRACTICALITY WON'T PART OF IT
THAT THE CHAIR MENTIONED IT
EARLIER IS THAT MICROGRAMS
REQUIRE IT TO TRULY BE FULLY
RESILIENT AN UNDERGROUND
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM ALONG WITH
IT.
SO THERE ARE SOME -- INHIBITING
FACTORS IF IT WENT WHEN YOU
REALLY START TO TO LOOK AT ITS
ITS APPLICATION IS A FIRE
RESILIENCE TOOL -- BUT WE WE DO
THINK THAT THERE MIGHT BE SOME
PLACES WHERE IT IT DOES HAVE ITS
PLACE IN THAT RESILIENCE
PORTFOLIO -- WHEN WE LOOK AT
HARDENING?
ARMED FORCES UNDER GROUNDING --
IT'S THERE THERE ARE TWO VERY
DIFFERENT COST -- COST.
PROFILES -- WERE UNDER GROUNDING
IS EXTENSIVELY MORE -- COST
PROHIBITIVE IN SOME CASES AND
PART OF THE THE REASON IS THAT.
YOU COULD REPLACE A LINE BUT TO
UNDERGROUND YOU MAY HAVE TO
FOLLOW A ROAD SYSTEM IT MAY TAKE.
FAR MORE UNDER GROUNDING TO
REPLACE IT THAN JUST FOLLOWING
THE PATH OF THE CURRENT OVERHEAD
WHICH CAN MAKE IT TANA VASTLY
MORE EXPENSIVE -- AND THEN IN
TERMS OF NINE OH ONE THERE'S A
CONTINUOUS EVOLUTION OF THIS PRO
OF OUR FIRE MITIGATION PROGRAM
THERE HAS BEEN FOR A DECADE IN
THERE WILL BE. NINE OH ONE THIS
IS A GUIDE YOU KNOW IT GUIDES
DOWN I RIGHTS WHAT WE'RE
PLANNING TO DO BUT THAT BEING
SAID AS TECHNOLOGY EVOLVES -- WE
CONTINUE TO EVOLVE WITH IT AND
WILL CAPTURE EVERYTHING WE'RE
DOING IN THESE PLANS BUT IT
WOULD NEVER PREVENT US FROM
EVOLVING OR INTEGRATING THE NEXT
TECHNOLOGY. FIVE PEOPLE JUST
ALONG TO THAT -- TO IN IN TERMS
OF MY PROGRESS I THINK THERE'S
ALSO THE ELEMENT FROM A BATTERY
STORAGE -- ENABLEMENT
PERSPECTIVE OF SPECIAL WE START
THINKING ABOUT THE DURATION OF
THE POTENTIAL DEALER DOES ATION
EVENTS SOME OF THESE.
ABOUT FLOOD WARNINGS ARE THE
CONDITIONS CAN LAST TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY SIX HOURS AND BUT AFTER
THAT CONDITION HAS PASSED ON THE
SYSTEM -- BUT WE WE CAN'T JUST
GO IN AND RE ENERGIZE WE INSURE
THAT WE DO THE SAFETY
INSPECTIONS.
ON ALL OF OUR DE ENERGIZED LINES
TO IDENTIFY ANY POTENTIAL IMPACT
THAT MAY HAVE OCCURRED SO WE
INSPECT EVERY INCH OF THE LINE
THAT WAS -- IMPACTED FROM
AUDIENCES ATION PERSPECTIVE
EITHER LEVERAGING AERIAL FLEET
OR QUALIFIED -- GROUND PERSONNEL
SO IN SOME CASES WE CAN HAVE AN
EVENT.
THAT MAY LAST MULTIPLE DAYS
THREE FOUR FIVE DAYS AND I THINK
FROM MY MY VANTAGE POINT YOU
KNOW THE AN ABLE MAN DOWN THE
CAPABILITY OF THE STORAGE MARKET
YOU KNOW IT IS AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT CONTINUES. TO EVOLVE FROM A
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCEMENT
PERSPECTIVE -- BUT IF I JUST
BUILD ON STREET DAY AUGUSTINE'S
POINT REGARDING SYSTEM HARDENING
AN UNDERGROUND.
THE DIMENSION THAT WE'VE LOOKED
AT THIS FROM.
VERY CONSISTENT -- AS WELL AS
OUTLINED.
BUT NOT JUST AT THE COST PIECE
IS ALSO A PACE PIECE OF THIS --
IN TERMS OF DOING UNDER
GROUNDING TAKES MUCH LONGER AND
THEN THE VIEW POINT THAT WE HAVE
ON THIS IS -- TO THE LONGER SOME
MEDICATIONS TAKE THE LONGER THE
WRIST EXPOSURES OUT THERE RIGHT
SO -- THAT THAT'S YOU KNOW BUT
ONE A DIMENSION OF THIS AS WELL
AND AND WE DO HAVE UNDER
GROUNDING.
AS A STRATEGIC.
INITIATIVE IF YOU WANT TO CALL
IT AS PART OF THE THE SUITE OF
SYSTEM -- HARDENING OF RENDON
RESILIENCY PROCESS OVERALL.
BECAUSE UNDER GROUNDING ALSO IS
NOT.
FREE FROM A RISK PERSPECTIVE YES
IT COMPLETELY YOU KNOW REDUCES
FOR THE MOST PART THE WILD FIRE
RISK BUT THERE'S OTHER ELEVATED
RISK THAT HAVE TO BE CONSIDERED
IN TERMS OF IMPACT AS A RESULT
OF POTENTIAL LANDSLIDE.
DICK AND SUSCEPTIBILITY. TO
MODEL REPAIR TIME IT TAKES WHEN
THERE'S AN IMPACT TO UNDERGROUND
LINE ALSO THERE'S A SET OF
ELEVATED.
OF RISK FACTORS THAT HAVE TO BE
CONSIDERED IN THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS.
AND THEN IN REGARDS TO THE
UPDATE FOR THE SB NOT A ONE
WE'RE GONNA BE FILING.
A LOT FOR MEDICATION PLAN ON
ANNUAL BASIS -- AND IN THE PLAN
OUTLINES.
YOU KNOW KIND OF THE THE THE
FLOOR FROM MY PERSPECTIVE ON YOU
KNOW ALL THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
ACTUALLY PUT FORWARD -- BUT IF
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT COMES
ALONG DURING THAT ONE YEAR TIME
FRAME THE ONLY FULLY ANTICIPATE --
TO IMPLEMENT AND LEVERAGE THAT
AND THEN MAKE THAT UPDATE -- AS
AT THE NEXT OPPORTUNITY WITHIN
THE BY THE TORY FALLING PROCESS.
THANKS TO I'M GONNA GET A
COLLEAGUES HAD MOST OF IT HERE --
AND I JUST A COUPLE OF EXTRA
POINTS -- THE GROWTH THINKING
ABOUT MICHAEL GOODS AND A GREAT
AND A GROUNDING IN A SIMILAR
CONTEXT WHICH IS THEIR
APPLICATIONS WHERE THAT IS A
GOOD SOLUTION BOTH PARKER GRADES
IN UNDERGROUND AND APPLICATIONS
WHERE IT'S NOT SO WE'RE LOOKING
AT THIS IS WHAT FITS BEST FOR
THE THE PARTICULAR APPLICATION.
AGAIN I THINK FOR US THE
UNDERGROUND AND ONE OF THEM IS --
MISTER SING AT THE IS THE TIME
IT ACTUALLY TAKES TO TO DO THIS
DEPLOYMENT ONE OF THE REASONS
WE'RE FOCUSING ON COVER
CONDUCTOR IS TO REALLY THE RAPID
REPEATEDLY WHICH WE CAN DEPLOY
THE SOLUTION.
AND GET MUCH OF THE BENEFIT OF
UNDERGROUND IN WITH A COVERING
NOT NOT ALL THAT MUCH OF IT SO --
THE YOU KNOW THOSE ARE THINGS WE
THINK THROUGH UNDERGROUND AND WE
WILL DO UNDER GROUNDING IS A
RELATES TO WALL FIRE MITIGATION
IS HE'S IS WHERE IT HAS A RIGHT
APPLICATION -- THE POINT I WOULD
ALSO CLOSE ON A CONTINUOUS
AMOUNT OF CHANGE THAT WE EXPECT
TO SEE BOB EVEN YEAR ON YEAR.
WE'RE SEEING NEW TECHNOLOGIES
EMERGE THE A FREQUENTLY NOW ONES
THAT HAVE A DIRECT APPLICATION.
ONE OF THE BIG ONES IS HOW ARE
USING DATA ANALYTICS IN MACHINE
LEARNING.
THEY THEY EVEN CAN FIND THEIR
WAY INTO SOME OF THE MORE BASIC
THINGS WERE DOING TERMS OF
LOCATING COVER CONDUCTOR AND
WORDS BASS AS WE GET MORE AND
MORE.
INFORMATION ALLOWS US TO
PRIORITIZE OR THE NEXT BEST MILE
IS THAT REALLY HELPS TO INFORM
US AND MANY SURE THAT WERE
REDUCING RISK AS QUICKLY AS WE
CAN.
SO YOU'LL SEE THAT YOU'LL SEE
THE NEW TECHNOLOGIES A RAPID
EARTH FALL LIMITERS -- OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES THAT THAT
ALTERNATELY WILL HELP US TO AN
EVEN BETTER JOB ONCE IT BUT
WE'RE PROBABLY NOT ENVISIONING
RIGHT NOW BUT IN TWO OR THREE
YEARS.
DEL MARCH AND WE WANT TO PULL
THOSE IN OUR PLAN -- THAT'S
THAT'S PART OF OUR PROGRAM AND
HOW WE'RE LOOKING AT IT.
I THINK IN JUST TWO QUICK THINGS.
ONE I MEAN AS WE KNOW IT'S
RAINING AGAIN RIGHT SO WE KNOW
WILDFIRE SEASON IS GOING TO BE.
IT'S GONNA BE ANOTHER BAD
[inaudible]
ONE I MEAN.
AND THIS IS A SOMEONE A
RHETORICAL QUESTION BUT HOW DO
WE TRUST THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE.
CONTINUING TO MAINTAIN
CONTINUING TO GO BACK I MEAN.
FOR THE SCIENTIFIC PROCESS RIGHT
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM WHAT'S THE
ANALYSIS WHAT'S THE AMP
IMPLEMENTATION AND WHAT'S THE
ONGOING EVALUATION.
HOW DO YOU HOW TO CONVINCE US IN
THE PUBLIC?
THAT THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
AND ENDED BY LAST QUESTION AS AN
ASIDE WERE YOU GETTING ALL THESE
WORKERS ARE LET'S TALK ABOUT
LABOR SHORTAGE IN GOING FROM
SIXTEEN HUNDRED ALMOST THREE
THOUSAND THAT'S A THAT WERE THEY
COMING FROM.
DACULA MISSING AS WELL JUST
WORKING BACKWARDS ON THE OF THE
LABOR SHOULD GET WE HAVE BROUGHT.
A HUNDREDS OF ADDITIONAL WORKERS
IN MANY FROM OUT OF STATE -- TO
HELP DO THIS WORK AND THE LABOR
MARKET IS GETTING TIGHT AND WE
WILL -- WE WILL SEE THAT --
WE'RE DOING A LOT OF INTERNAL
TRAINING AS WELL WERE WE LOOKING
AT HOW WE DO SOME THINGS WITH A
NOD TO EFFICIENCY THIS IS
PERHAPS LESS ON THE THE THE THE
THE ACTUAL A DEPLOYMENT THE
RESOURCES BUT THE PLANNING IN
THE ENGINEERING RESOURCES. TO
WILL HAVE TO HIT WITH TECHNOLOGY
WITH TRAINING AND AND AGAIN --
BY HAVING MORE MORE WORKERS
TRAINED TO DO THIS -- ONE OF
THINGS THAT -- WE'RE WE'RE NOT
KIDDING OURSELVES THIS IS NOT A
SHORT TERM PROBLEM THIS IS A
LONG TERM PROBLEM.
AND SO AS WE CATCH UP I THINK
THE LABOR WILL COME BECAUSE THIS
IS I THINK -- SOMETHING WHERE WE
WILL BE DOING THIS WORK FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND THESE ARE --
IT GIVES ARE.
PLACES WHERE WE NEED HIGHLY
QUALIFIED TRAINED INDIVIDUALS
AND AND WE WANT THEM HERE SO I I
THINK WE'LL WE'LL WE'LL GET THAT
RESPONSE RIGHT NOW IT IS VERY
TIGHT -- IN TERMS OF CONVINCING --
EVERYONE THAT THIS IS THIS IS
OUR YOUTH ASSIST REALLY IS WHAT
WE'RE ABOUT NOW THIS IS -- HOW
WE ARE FOCUSED AS AN
ORGANIZATION I I CAN TELL YOU IT
IS FROM THE TOP DOWN OF THIS
ENTERPRISE?
THAT WHILE FAR MITIGATION IS OUR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY -- WE ARE
FOCUSED AND MORE MAIN FOCUS ON
CONTINUING TO CHALLENGE
OURSELVES AND WE HAVE A SEPARATE
OFFICE DEDICATED TO JUST THIS
ISSUE AND JUST THESE.
SWEET OF THINGS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT TO DO JUST THAT TO
LOOK AT WHAT'S THE STATE OF THE
INDUSTRY WAS A STATE OF
TECHNOLOGY WAS A STATE OF
SCIENTIFIC THINKING AROUND THIS
SO -- I THINK WE'VE WE'VE
DEVOLVED MUSCLE MEMORY HERE AND
CHALLENGING THE WAY WE THINK
ABOUT THINGS AND THIS IS A I
PERSONALLY COMMITTED TO THIS.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING WE'LL SEE
OVER TIME IS HOW WE HOW WE
ACTUALLY DEPLOY OUR OUR
SOLUTIONS AND CONTINUE TO
CHALLENGE OURSELVES.
JUSTICE FOR THAT ADD ON TO THAT --
JUST IN TERMS OF THE THE LABOR
ELEMENT YOUR QUESTION ABOUT HOW
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO ATTRACT --
THE RESOURCES SO WE'VE HAD TO DO
IT AT A PREMIUM ACOSTA PREMIUM --
AND AND THAT'S NOT SUSTAINABLE
OF FOR THE COST PREMIUM IN TERMS.
SO SO SO SO BE IT IN TERMS OF TO
TERMS AND CONDITIONS -- FOR THE
CONTRACTORS RIGHT SO THERE'S A
HIGHER HIGHER COST.
OF STRUCTURE IN TERMS OF LABOR
HOURS AS AN EXAMPLE -- THAT WE
PUT FORWARD TO BE ABLE TO BRING
THE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AND AND
THE REASON I BROUGHT THAT UP AS
A BARRIER IS WE'VE REALLY.
HITTING CALM THE MARKET CAP --
AND IT'S NOT A SUSTAINABLE WAY
FOR US TO CONTINUE TO DO THIS IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW PAYING
INDIVIDUALS ARE OUT OF STATE --
ON A ON AN ESCALATED CALL
STRUCTURE WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT RESOURCES
THAT'S GOING TO BE A CRITICAL
ASPECT OF WHAT'S NEEDED WITHIN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
GOING FORWARD SO WE NEED A
LONGER TERM.
LABOR RESOURCE -- PROGRAM IN
TERMS OF APPRENTICESHIP AND I
THINK THERE'S REALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY NOT JUST FOR THE
THREE I'LL USE HERE BUT SOME OF
THE THE STATE ENTITIES U. S. FOR
SERVICES OF LEVERAGES THEM FROM.
OF EDUCATION MATCHING
PERSPECTIVE SO HOW DO WE REALLY
GROW -- CALIFORNIA LABOR MARKET
AS IT PERTAINS TO THE THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT RESOURCES
IT'S IT'S A REAL ISSUE -- THAT
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT AND BUT
REALLY WILLING TO PARTNER TO
ESTABLISH A LONG TERM.
SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION
[inaudible]
SKINNER CITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
CONTINUE.
MS EGGMAN QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
UNDER GROUNDING -- YOU YOU TALK
ABOUT COVER CONDUCTORS SICK OF
BEING A LOT CHEAPER THAN
UNDERGROUND YOU CAN YOU CAN YOU
GIVE US A SENSE AS TO WHAT ORDER
OF A YEAH IT'S PROBABLY A FACTOR
OF EIGHT SO HE TO WE OUR RULE OF
THUMB IS UNDER GROUNDING IS
ROUGHLY THREE MILLION.
DOLLARS A CIRCUIT MILE -- COVER
CONDUCTOR IS ROUGHLY FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY DEPORTED SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A CIRCUIT MILE
OKAY AND DO YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY.
PROGRAMS WHERE.
YOU WOULD SHARE THE COST WITH
WITH CITIES IF IF CITIES WERE
WILLING TO A FOOT FOR FOOT IN
I'M A PART OF THE BILL THEY THEY
YOU WOULD
PARTNER AND PERHAPS PRIORITIZE
UNDER GROUNDINGS IN COMMUNITIES
WE HAVE A RULE TWENTY PROGRAMS
THOSE ARE GENERALLY AND FRANKLY
FOR AESTHETIC PURPOSES -- IS A
CONVERSATION WERE WERE WILLING
TO HAVE A SISTER THERE ISN'T A
TERRAPIN PLACE FOR US IN IN
SOCAL EDISON -- TO APPROACH ON A
GROUNDING AS A RISK MITIGATION
METHOD IN A COST SHARING
MECHANISM.
OKAY AND AND AND SO THAT WOULD --
TO IN IN TERMS OF THE EXISTING
PROGRAM FOR STATIC PURPOSES IS
IS SAID -- TO IT IS IS AT A
ARRANGEMENT THAT YOU DIRECTLY
ENTER INTO A CITIES ORDERED A
DIEGO THROUGH THE CPC TO YEAH IT
IT'S ROLE -- TWENTY IT'S RULE
TWENTY EIGHT SO WE HAVE --
PROGRAMS WHERE CREDITS ARE
BANKED IN CITIES CAN USE THOSE
CREDITS -- AND APPLY THEM
TOWARDS -- TOWARDS UNDER
GROUNDING EFFORTS OKAY.
ALL RIGHT PHAM.
AND THEN I WANTED TO GO MOVE OUT
I SAID I GOT STARTS ARE NOT TO
TO NO NO I DON'T BUT I DO I DO I
GET BACK TO ONE OF THE COST IS
JUST ONE OF THE DIMENSIONS.
WITH THE TIME TO DEPLOY HE IS A
KEY -- ONE AND ALSO THE AMOUNT
OF ADDITIONAL MILES BUT REALLY
TIME TO DEPLOY WANT ONE OF THESE
ARE VERY FOCUSED ON IS REDUCING
THE RISK AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN SO
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE KEY
ELEMENTS OF THE OF THE PROGRAM.
OF COURSE SO I WENT WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT TARGETING TARGETED
UNDER GROUNDING IN THE YEAR WE
ARE YOU HEY HOW ARE YOU
TARGETING IT WOULD BE WHERE WE
WOULD IDENTIFY -- GREATER LEVELS
OF REST THAT -- CAN BE DONE --
IN A YOU KNOW IT'S AN
EXPEDITIOUS WAY SO IT WILL BE
PART OF THE PORTFOLIO GOING
FORWARD -- AND IT IT'S IT'S IN
THE PROGRAM.
ALL RIGHT.
THUMB AND THEN I WANTED TO A OF
TURN TO I I DON'T KNOW IF -- THE
THE PANELISTS RECEIVED -- TO THE
MEMO THAT WE RECEIVED AS AS PART
OF THIS INFORMATION HEARING BUT
IT LOOKS LIKE THE THE THEIR PC
IS GOING TO BE -- ASKING THE I.
O. U.'S FOR METRICS THAT ARE
FOCUSING NOT ON THE NUMBER OF
ACTIONS TAKEN BUT INSTEAD ON HOW
THOSE ACTIONS MEASURABLY REDUCE
THE RISK OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE -- I I I IMAGINE GIVEN
THAT.
LOOKS LIKE THERE'S A JULY
DEADLINE THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON
THAT BUT TO CAN YOU CAN YOU GIVE
US A PREVIEW AS TO WHAT SOME OF
THOSE -- THOSE -- THEY THE
GENERAL PARAMETERS OF THOSE
METRICS WOULD LOOK LIKE.
SURE I CAN START OFF IN THE NINE
BUT MY COLLEAGUES TO A CHIME IN --
SO SO WE'RE LOOKING AT BOTH
OUTCOME BASED METRICS -- REALLY
FROM A A LEADING AND A LAGGING --
PERSPECTIVE SOAP UP EXAMPLE OF A
LAGGING INDICATOR -- IS A FIRE
IGNITION -- OF OF A SMALL SIZE A
AS AN EXAMPLE AND WE OF
IDENTIFIES AS MR DEL CASTILLO
STATED BEFORE SO ANY IGNITION --
WE CHARACTERIZE WHAT IS THE
ACTUAL COST OF THAT IGNITION SO
WAS THAT.
A RESULT OF EQUIPMENT ISSUE --
WAS THAT A RESULT OF VEGETATION
VEGETATION POTENTIALLY COMING IN
CONTACT WITH A BARE WIRE THE
BECAUSE THE OUR COURSE BARK SO.
LOOKING AT THE VARIOUS IGNITION
DRIVERS THAT RESULT IN THE
POTENTIAL FAR ADDITION TO THAT'S
MORE OF A LAGGING INDICATOR.
THE COROLLARY TO THAT FOR A
LEADING INDICATOR ISRAELI
OUTAGES -- THAT ARE CAUSED BY
THOSE SAME TYPES OF DRIVERS SO
AS WE LOOK AT THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE ENHANCE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM OR THE
INSPECTION PROCESS OR THE SYSTEM
HARDENING THE REALLY GEARED
TOWARDS REDUCE SAYING.
NOT ONLY THE NUMBER OF IGNITION
CAUSED BY VEGETATION OR
EQUIPMENT DRIVEN ISSUES BUT ALSO
OUTAGES OUTAGES IS WHERE WE MAY
HAVE -- A IMPACT EITHER -- OF
VEGETATION -- COMING IN CONTACT
WITH A LINE THAT CREATES WHAT'S
CALLED A FAULT -- AND EITHER
THERE'S A MOMENTARY OR SUSTAINED
OUT AGE.
WHERE IT IMPACTS THE CIRCUIT AND
THE CIRCUIT BASICALLY OPENS
MEETING THAT THERE'S NO
ELECTRICITY FLOWING THROUGH IT
ANYMORE -- AND REALLY WE ARE
USING A THINKING ABOUT THE OUR
AGE AS THE LEADING INDICATOR --
TO THE LAGGING INDICATOR A FAR
DISTANCE A TRACKING BOTH OF
THOSE AND AS WE CONTINUE TO
IMPLEMENT THE RISK REDUCTION
MEASURES.
NOW IS SEEING A DECLINE IN THE
OPERATIONAL PERFORMANCE IF YOU
WANT TO CALL IT OF THOSE
RESPECTIVE VEGETATION OR
EQUIPMENT COSTS OUTRAGEOUS.
WHERE WERE IN A SIMILAR --
APPROACHING US IN A SIMILAR WAY
I THINK ONE OF THE CHALLENGES IN
SOME OF THE UC OUTCOME BASED
EARLY ON IT IS THE AOUNT OF
VOLATILITY IS GOING TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM GIVEN THE
SIZE OF OUR SYSTEM.
WOW QUICKLY YOU'LL SEE SOME OF
THESE BUT THEY THEY THEY WILL
BECOME A PART OF HOW WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
OUR PROGRAMS OVERALL -- AND AND
WE'RE FRANKLY APPROACHING THIS
THE SAME WAY THAT PROBABLY THE
ONLY THING I WOULD ADD IS --
WHERE WE ARE NOW IS REGARDLESS
OF LOCATION OF OF -- OF A
CIRCUIT PROBLEM WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING AT OUR SYSTEM -- NOT
JUST IN HIGH FIRE IS SCARY BUT
ON THE NON HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS --
BECAUSE THINGS THAT OCCUR ON
SOMETHING ABOUT HOW THE SYSTEM
OVERALL CAN OPERATE.
SO IF WE HAVE AN EVENT --
QUALITY -- MYLAR BALLOON COMES
IN CONTACT WITH THE CIRCUIT IN A
NON HIGH FOR A RISK AREA -- WILL
EVALUATE THAT IT MAY BE THE KEY --
CAUSES EVIDENT OR SELF EVIDENT
WHEN YOU SEE WHAT'S HAPPENED BUT
IT WILL TELL US SOMETHING ABOUT
PERHAPS WE SHOULD BE DOING
DIFFERENTLY.
IN OTHER SPACES HI FIRE RISK
AREAS IN TERMS OF MITIGATION
EFFORTS IN THE CASE WHERE IT
DOES MAKE A BIGGER DIFFERENCE IF
WE HAVE AN EVENT THAT HAPPENED
SO.
WE'RE ESSENTIALLY GOING OUT AND
DOING ANALYSES OF ALL OF OUR
FAULTS -- AND WE'RE GOING TO
DRESS THOSE IN THE PROGRAMS AND
STANDARDS WE PUT IN PLACE FOR
THE HIGHER FIRE RISK AREAS.
YES IN FROM OUR STANDPOINT WERE
LINING CLOSELY I'D SECOND EVERY
EVERYTHING WE HEARD AND PER THE
PROPOSED -- DECISION ON THE WILD
FIRE MITIGATION PLAN WE WILL ALL
BE ALIGNING EVEN MORE CLOSELY
MOVING FORWARD.
WE PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON THE
PERFORMANCE OF OUR PROJECTS
BECAUSE WHEN WE START LOOKING AT
THINGS LIKE NUMBER OF IGNITIONS
THE REALITY IS -- DROUGHT HAS A
MAJOR IMPACT A NUMBER OF
IGNITIONS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THINGS LIKE WIRES DOWN.
THE SEVERITY OF WINTER STORMS
HAS MAJOR IMPACTS OF SOME OF
THESE THINGS WHAT WE HAVE TO
NORMALIZE THEM AND FIND WAYS. TO
TO MAKE IT SO THAT THEY DON'T
SKEW ALL THE INFORMATION BUT
THAT BEING SAID WILL BE WORKING
TOGETHER ON THIS MOVING FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT.
AND MY MY LAST QUESTION -- IS --
WITH THIS MEMO THAT DISCUSSES
THAT RAISES THE ISSUE OF FOR
WHETHER THE PC HAS THE THE
CAPACITY. TO TO BE AN ADEQUATE --
SAFETY REGULATOR IN ADDITION TO
ALL OF THEIR OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES AND I I LIKE
AND KNOW IT.
MAYBE AWKWARD TO A TO TO
EVALUATE THE EVALUATOR -- OR BUT
I WAS WONDERING IF -- IF YOU YOU
CAN OFFER ANY.
ANY THOUGHTS AS TO WHETHER THE
PC IS UP -- TO THE IT HAS IT HAS
THE NECESSARY -- CAPACITY. TO TO
TO TO TO EVALUATE INTO OF
OVERSEE THE THE THE THE THE
WHILE FAR SAFETY.
MEASURES THAT THE I. O. USER
TAKING.
AND IF I POOR WILL WELCOME YOUR
RESPONSE TO THIS QUESTION BUT WE
DO HAVE ANOTHER PANEL THAT
SQUARE AUDITOR'S NOW THAT'S A
QUICK. TO FOCUS ON OVERSIGHT SO.
IF YOU DO HAVE A RESPONSE WHICH
I DO WELCOME -- JUST MAKE IT A
QUICK RESPONSE SO THAT WE CAN
HELLO THE NEXT BATTLE TO GET.
TWO MORE INTO THE WEEDS ON IT IF
YOU.
I I WOULD JUST SAY -- I I THINK
THIS IS GOING TO BE A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS ACROSS THE
BOARD -- I I THINK YOU KNOW THE
THE COMMISSION.
HAS A RESOURCES AND IS THE REAL
QUESTION IS JUST HOW WE PARTNER
IS -- TO TO MOVE FORWARD ON THIS
I THINK IT'S WE WE NEED GUIDANCE
AND STRUCTURE AROUND WHAT WE'RE
DOING CAN BE VERY HELPFUL.
WE HAVE THAT IS -- ENTERPRISES
NOT JUST WITH OURSELVES BUT ALSO
OUTSIDE OF HIS COLLABORATED ON
TRYING TO FIND THE BEST
SOLUTIONS THAT WE CAN TO
MITIGATE WILDFIRE RISK -- WE WE
DON'T WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH WITH AGENCIES
AND THE CBC AND ARE GOVERNED
PARTNERS AT CAL -- AWESOME MERCY
SERVICES CAL FIRE AND OTHERS
BECAUSE I DO THINK THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT -- ANYONE
ENTERPRISE OR AGENCY REALLY --
CAN ADDRESS I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO TAKE.
A LOT OF RESOURCES AND A LOT OF
AGENCIES A LOT OF DIFFERENT --
IMPORTS ACROSS THE THE
REGULATORY LEGISLATIVE COMPLEX
AS WELL AS ENTITIES LIKE
OURSELVES WHO WERE OR BE
REGULATED AND WE WE HAVE PART OF
THE SOLUTION.
SO IT'S IT'S GOING TO BE A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT SO I'D
RATHER NOT ADDRESS THAT DUDE'S
GOT THE CAPABILITY BECAUSE I I I
REALLY THINK -- YOU COULD
STRUCTURE AT HOWEVER YOU NEEDED
TO WHATEVER AGENCIES HAVE THE
CAPABILITY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE CITY IS CLICK -- I'M SORRY
WE HAVE YEAH ONE MORE QUESTION
THE FREE IS THERE ANYONE ELSE ON
THE COMMITTEE BECAUSE I WOULD
LIKE.
TO OKAY OKAY DOCTOR QUIRK -- SO
YOU'RE.
YOUR HEDGED IN AND HOW FAST YOU
CAN DO THIS BY A NUMBER OF
FACTORS.
A ONE OF THEM OF COURSE IS
REACHING OUT TO THE PUBLIC ON
TREES AND POWER -- SHUT OFFS I
WOULD JUST STRESS THAT YOU TAKE
SAFETY IS THE NUMBER ONE CONCERN
TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU CAN.
REACH OUT THAT'S WONDERFUL BUT
PLEASE CUT THE TREES IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD IF YOU HAVE TO DO
IT RIGHT AWAY AND TURN OFF THE
POWER WHEN YOU NEED TO I'LL I'LL
SURVIVE.
YOU MAY NEED -- PROTECTION FROM
SUITS IF THAT'S AN ISSUE YOU
NEED TO BRING THAT TO US.
OUR BECAUSE PEOPLE MAY SUE OVER
TREES CUT OR POWER BEING SHUT
OFF AND LOSSES OF ONE TYPE OR
ANOTHER.
AND YOU ALREADY ADDRESSED THE
SAFETY CONCERNS OVER SHUTTING
OFF POWER WHICH IS ONE REASON IT
HASN'T BEEN ROUTINE BEFORE THIS --
YOU'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT COST
VERSUS SAFETY.
WE ONLY HAVE TO AVOID ONE OR TWO
FIRES EVERY DECADE OF THAT SORT
OF CATASTROPHIC TYPE WE'VE HAD.
TO MAKE IT WORTH WHILE TO MAYBE
DO UNDER GROUNDING VERSUS -- I
WORKING ON THE CONDUCTORS.
SO.
I THINK SOMEBODY SHOULD.
SEE IF THERE'S A REAL DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN UNDER GROUNDING.
AND MAKING THE WIRE SAY -- FOR
WITH THE SYSTEM SUCH AS CUTTING
OFF THE POWER WHEN THE LINE
BREAKS IT CETERA WHAT'S THE COST
OF THAT FIRST IS THE COST OF
UNDERGROUND IN AND BY THE WAY ON
THE GROUND IN THIS YOU MENTIONED
ALSO MEANS A LOT MORE
MAINTENANCE.
BUT IF WE COULD SEE WHAT WHAT
THOSE COSTS ARE AND LOOK AT THEM
SIDE BY SIDE.
AND DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT IT
SAVES A CATASTROPHIC FIRE EVERY
DECADE OR TWO IT MIGHT BE WORTH
IT AND I'M JUST SAYING PLEASE DO
NOT RULE THAT OUT AND PLEASE
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
UP FINALLY YOU MENTIONED THE
NUMBER OF THINGS THAT PREVENT
YOU FROM -- MAKING PROGRESS AS
FAST AS YOU'D LIKE SHORTNESS OF
SHORTNESS OF LABOR.
AND THEIR ALTHOUGH YOU'RE
BRINGING IN TRAIN PEOPLE FROM
OUT OF STATE.
WE HAD TO HAVE A LOT OF
UNEMPLOYED PEOPLE AND YOU'VE
TALKED ABOUT -- HAVING
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND SUCH
TO DO THE TRAINING TO THE EXTENT
YOU CAN DO THAT.
I WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE AREAS WITH
VERY HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT.
AND WE WOULD HOPE THAT THOSE
FOLKS WOULD BE ABLE -- TO DO
THAT WORK.
THEN FINALLY I'M JUST TRYING TO
GET AN IDEA OF WHAT'S REALLY
SLOWING YOU DOWN -- SO YOU
MENTIONED THERE'S NO TERRA FOR
UNDERGROUND IN WHICH FOR PEOPLE
ME FOR THE FOR NORMAL PEOPLE
THAT MEANS YOU HAVE NO SOURCES
OF FUNDING.
THAT WOULD BE AN ISSUE THAT WE
GO THROUGH THE C. P. U. C..
V. R. CHAIR OF THE P. YOU SEE
WHEN HE'S BEEN HERE HAS SAID
THEY HAVE TOO MANY THINGS TO DO
ALREADY -- HE'S TALKED ABOUT
GETTING RID OF IN THIS IS
PROBABLY SOMETHING WE SHOULD
LOOK AT TOGETHER WITH THE
PRESIDENT THE C. P. U. C. AS I
LOOK OVER TO THE CHAIR HERE --
HE'S TALKED ABOUT MOVING TRUCK
BEING AND OTHER SUCH AREAS OUT
OF THE C. P. U. C.. FOR WHICH
THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERTISE IN TRYING TO LIMIT
WHAT THEY CAN LOOK AT AND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD
BE DOING.
BUT THEN WHAT MY REAL QUESTION
DEALS WITH WHAT REALLY IS
SLOWING YOU DOWN IS IT A LACK OF
CAPITAL OF MONEY.
IS THE LACK OF WORKERS -- EASY
JUST TAKING LONG TIME TO GET --
BUREAUCRATIC APPROVALS FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING -- FOR PER
DAY FOR PERMISSION TO DO THINGS
A PARTICULAR WAY WHAT REALLY IS --
THE PROBLEM WITH THE IN TERMS OF
NOT BEING ABLE TO GO AS FAST AS
YOU MIGHT LIKE.
TO TIPS SO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT THANKS FOR
THE COMMENTS ON THE AND THE
QUESTION FROM FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
BEEN THE OTHER QUALIFIED
WORKFORCE.
THAT THAT'S ONE KEY ELEMENT -- A
IN SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PIECE SAYS.
BEEN I PUT FORWARD -- BLAST AT
THE END OF LAST YEAR.
WE PRETTY MUCH OF WERE OFFERING.
KIND OF A HOURLY RATE RIGHT AT
WHAT TIME AND PUT AND IT'S IT'S
CALLED THE HIGHEST RATE POSSIBLE
WITHIN THE THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT.
OF SPACE AND WHAT WE WERE
FINDING IS THAT THERE'S KIND OF
THAT LIMITATION ON THE
QUALIFICATION OF THE INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE THAT THE WARRICK --
ITSELF IS ONE OF THE HIGHLY
HAZARDOUS TASKS THAT'S DONE
WITHIN THE NATION RIGHT NOW WE
LOOK AT LOGGING.
AND NOW WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TRIMMING IN AND AROUND --
ENERGIZED ELECTRICAL LINES IT'S
ONE OF THE HIGHEST HAZARDOUS
TASSEL REQUIRES A TRAINED
PROFESSIONAL AN INDIVIDUAL AND
WHAT WE WERE IDENTIFYING.
IS OVER TIME AS WE WERE
CONTINUING TO OFFER INCENTIVES
TO BE ABLE TO BRING THE
RESOURCES OF EVER GETTING
RESOURCES THAT WERE NOT
QUALIFIED TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
WORK AS AS WE WERE DOING THE
SAFETY OBSERVATION SO THERE'S
KIND OF THAT -- BUREAU OF FINITE
SET OF POPULATION OF A NUMBER OF
QUALIFIED PERSONNEL SO THAT'S
ONE ONE DIMENSION.
THE OTHER DIMENSION IS -- IN
THIS IS NOT WITH ALL OF THE
ENTITIES WE WE HAVE FOUND MUCH
BETTER ENGAGEMENT PARTNERSHIP
COOPERATION.
WHETHER IT'S PRIVATE CUSTOMERS
OR IT'S THE VARIOUS ENTITIES TO
BE ABLE TO GET THE NECESSARY
ENVIRONMENTAL PERMITTING -- THE
ENDANGERED SPECIES -- SO THOSE
ARE SOME OF THE OTHER ELEMENTS
WORKING WITH THE VARIOUS FOR
SERVICE ENTITIES -- THE BUREAU
OF LAND MANAGEMENT AS AN EXAMPLE
THERE'S THE FEDERAL OR STATE
ENTITY -- THERE'S A LOT THAT
WE'RE DOING AND THEY'RE REALLY
STEPPING UP TO THE PLATE IN
TERMS OF DEVELOPING -- HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLANS THAT ARE PRE
ESTABLISHED WITH THE MEDICATION
PRACTICES ALSO THERE'S A LOT
THAT'S BEEN DONE IN THAT SPACE --
BUT NOT THOSE ALSO TEND TO BE --
ELEMENTS FOR SOME OF THE AREAS
WHERE IT TAKES A LITTLE BIT
LONGER TO BE ABLE.
TO DO THE NEGOTIATION WITHOUT
SOME OF THE CUSTOMERS THAT
REALLY LOVE THEIR TREE THAT WE
DON'T UNDERSTAND KIND OF THE
WRIST A WE'RE TRYING TO PUT
FORWARD.
ALSO SOME OF THOSE -- CHALLENGES
STILL EXIST OUT THERE YEAH TO
THE EXTENT TO WHICH YOU COULD
USE LEGISLATIVE HELP I WOULD
HELP HOPE THAT YOU WORK -- TO
LET US KNOW THAT.
AND THAT WOULD BE VERY USEFUL --
THEN I HAVE A QUESTION A
PARTICULAR FOUR EDITION -- HOW
MUCH IS THIS GOING TO COST YOU I
DON'T S. P. JEANNIE BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN BANKRUPTCY?
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY CAN
SAY OR WHAT THEY CAN'T SAY BUT
SINCE YOU ARE LOOKING AT THIS
OUT LONG TERM.
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION A BILLION TEN BILLION I
I JUST A BALLPARK IT.
RIGHT NOW IT TO AGAIN LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE THE TIME DURATION OF
COURSE AND MOON PROCESS OF
PREPARING OUR NEXT GENERAL RIGHT
CASE -- WHICH WE EXPECT TO
SUBMIT LATER THIS YEAR -- WHAT
WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US NOW IS A
PROGRAM BY -- NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND TWENTY AND THAT'S
SEVERAL HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR COVER CONDUCTOR IN THAT
PERIOD OF TIME NOT AND OTHER
MITIGATION ACTIVITIES -- AS WE
CONTINUE TO EXPAND THIS WE WILL
BE LOOKING AT NUMBERS -- YOU
KNOW NORTH OF THE BILLION
DOLLARS THIS IS A A LARGE SYSTEM
WE'RE COVERING AND ADDRESSING
AND SO IT WILL -- IT WILL COME
WITH COST -- IT IS SOMETHING
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO JUST ALSO
WOULD SPEAK TO THE THE LABOR
ISSUE BECAUSE IT BECAUSE THAT IS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE ARE
PUSHING HARD ON JUST UNDERSCORE --
THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT IS ONE
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET
ADDITIONAL CREWS AND AND KEEP
OUR WORK MOVING.
OUT WE CAN ALWAYS USE MORE.
BUT WE THINK ABOUT THE TRAIN
LINE CREWS -- YOU KNOW THOSE
APPRENTICE PROGRAMS ARE THREE
YEARS LONG.
AND EVEN WHEN YOU BRING
RESOURCES IN FROM OUT OF STATE
THEY NEED TO BE TRAINED AND
UNDERSTAND OUR SYSTEM AND OUR
WEEK WAY OF DOING THINGS.
THAT IS NOT JUST PARTICULARITIES
IT'S ACTUALLY ELECTRICAL SYSTEMS
FROM UTILITY UTILITY SOMETIMES
DIFFER IN MEANINGFUL WAYS --
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS WE
TALK ABOUT PAYS WE TALK ABOUT
THE RESOURCES WE NEED TO BRING
ON BOARD.
WE ALSO NEED TO BRING ON BOARD --
WORKERS WHO OPERATE SAFELY AND
ARE NOT A HAZARD TO THEMSELVES
AND AND HAZARD TO PEOPLE AROUND
THEM AND THAT YOU CAN DO THE
WORK IN A QUALITY WAY.
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IF WE DO A LOT
OF INFRASTRUCTURE WORK AND IS
NOT DONE -- TO THE QUALITY
STANDARDS WE NEED.
WE WE REALLY HAVEN'T DONE
OURSELVES ANY FAVOR THE
MITIGATION SPACE OKAY SO.
THE OTHER THING IS TO GET THE
BILLION DOLLARS I ASSUME YOU BE
BORROWING MONEY AND THEN HAVING
THAT HAVE PAID BACK BY RATE
PAYERS OVER TIME.
THAT'S CORRECT.
AND THEN.
GIVEN THAT.
YOU'VE BEEN DOWNGRADED SO GO
LATELY IN YOUR ABILITY TO BORROW
YOU'RE JUST BARELY ABOVE.
JUNK BOND STATUS.
HOW MUCH MORE SAID GUN IS THAT
GONNA LIKE DOUBLE THE COSTS TO
RATEPAYERS OR?
ARMS OF THE INTEREST RATE YEAH
SOME AND I DON'T HAVE THOSE
FIGURES HANDY THEY THEY WILL
DRIVE COSTS UP -- IN A IN A NOT
INSUBSTANTIAL WAY THOUGH AND I
THINK THAT THOSE COSTS WILL BE
PASSED ON THROUGH BILLS OKAY SO
THE I WON'T ASK THE REST OF YOU
TO TALK TO BE -- THE BEING
NOTICED THAT THE CHAIR WANTS TO
MOVE THIS ALONG THANK YOU OKAY.
WE DO APPRECIATE YOUR BEING HERE
MISTER THE AGOSTINO HURTS AND
THEN MR SAYING -- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING YOU COME BACK
THIS IS SAYS ROOF NOTED -- IN
OUR ANALYSIS AND AS WE'VE SHARED
AND YOU'VE ALWAYS SEE RESPONDED
TO THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF A
NEW ERA OF HOW WE'RE GOING TO
TRY TO PREPARE.
AND WORK WITH YOU TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'RE IN THE BEST POSITION
TO SEE THAT YOUR PLANS ARE
APPROVED AND THAT THEY'RE
COVERING THE KINDS OF ISSUES
THAT THE WHO KEEP THE COMMUNITY
SAFE.
OF OUR NEXT PANEL WILL LOOK AT
OVERSIGHT AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S THE OTHER PART OF THE
EQUATION HERE SO.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR FOR BEING
HERE AND WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR CONVERSATION WITH
YOU THANK CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MAY
I MAKE CHAIRMAN AND IF WE CAN
CALL FORWARD THE OUR SECOND
PANEL ON OVERSIGHT AND
EVALUATION -- ELISABETH A MALLET
CINCO -- DEPUTY EXECUTIVE RECTOR
SAFETY IN ENFORCEMENT CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
DANIEL BURLAP ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CHIEF OF PLANNING AND
RISK ANALYSIS OUR ENGINEERING
AND INVESTIGATIONS DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION.
AND ROSS BROWN PRINCIPLE FISCAL
AND POLICY ANALYSIS LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE WELCOME IS TO HAVE YOU HERE
AND IF WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE YOU
START IN THE ORDER THAT YOUR
CALL FOR DAVID.
APPRECIATE HEARING YOUR
PRESENTATION AND AS YOU KNOW.
AND PART OF THE EARLIER --
HEARING OR PANEL DISCUSSION --
THE ISSUE OF YOU SEE OVERSIGHT
IN THE ABILITY TO ADDRESS ALL
THESE VERY NEEDS OF THAT FALL
WITH UNDER WITHIN THE PC -- TO
BE ABLE TO BE IN A POSITION.
TO BE RESPONSIVE TO THE SAFETY
ISSUES I THINK IS SORT OF UP
FRONT.
A QUESTION IS IN FRONT OF US BUT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS AND ANY QUESTIONS OR
MAY HAVE.
AFTER THAT.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M GIVING.
TO THE TRADE KEEP MY REMARKS
SHORT TO LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
QUESTIONS AND MIND HIS VIEW TO
MOTION COULD THE P. EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION --
AND EIGHT EIGHT THINK OF GOING
TO START OFF BY SAYING THAT'S
WHEN IT COMES TO UTILITY WILD
FIRE.
RESPONSE MITIGATION ELM AND
EFFORTS THAT THE ARE PUTTING IN
PLACE NO PLEA BOOK THAT YOU CAN
POINT TO TO SAY THIS IS WHAT A
UTILITY SHOULD BE DOING -- THERE
ARE BEST PRACTICES -- OUT THERE
AND THAT'S BEEN MY EIGHT TOP
FOCUS OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS IS TO IDENTIFY THEM AND
SPEAKING WITH.
REGULATORS IN THE THIS RALLY AND
COUNTED IN OF THE STATE'S.
WITH UTILITIES AND OTHER EXPERTS.
AND BRINGING THEM TOGETHER TO
CALIFORNIA WE HAD A WELFARE IT'S
COLLEGE INNOVATION SUMMIT'S IN
MARCH OF THIS YEAR.
L. FOR THAT PURPOSE TO HAVE THE
DIALOGUE AND SO WHILE.
THERE ARE BEST PRACTICES AND
REALLY GOOD IDEAS THAT EXIST.
THERE IS NO SINGLE ANSWER TO
THIS QUESTION AND THERE IS NO
STANDARD IN THE INDUSTRY -- THAT
EXISTS SO AS OF TODAY.
THE THERE IS NOTHING THERE'S NO
FRAMEWORK IN THERE'S NO STANDARD
FOR THE COMMISSION TO EVALUATE
THE WELFARE MITIGATION PLANS.
AGAINST WE ALL CAN HAVE OUR OWN
OPINIONS AS TO WHAT THE
UTILITIES ARE DOING ENOUGH WELL
OR NOT SO WITH THE RIGHT KINDS
OF THINGS BUT THERE'S NO.
THERE'S THERE'S NOTHING THAT'S
BEEN AGREED UPON BY A EXPERTS IN
THE SPACE.
HELLO MY AND THAT I WOULD SAY
THE CHALLENGE FROM A FROM A
REGULATORY PERSPECTIVE THE CPUC
PROCESS.
THE THE COMMISSION OUT FUNCTIONS
LOU LOU LIKE A COURTS IN MANY
WAYS -- AND IS IN THE WHOLE
WORLD.
IN ALL OUR EFFORTS.
AND ILL THE WAY THE PROCESS
WORKS IS WHEN THE UTILITIES --
IN THIS CASE SUBMITS WELFARE
MITIGATION PLANS AS APPLICATIONS
OF THE COMMISSION OPENS A
PROCEEDING AND ALLOWS FOR ARE
THE PARTIES TO COMMENTS AND THEN
THE STAFF IS SUPPOSED TO HOLD.
THE COMMISSION ADVISORY CAPACITY
TO EVALUATE THE DIFFERENT
COMMENTS THE THE ORIGINAL
APPLICATION IN THE COMMENTS FROM
VARIOUS PARTIES.
AND THEN HOLD THE COMMISSION
COME UP WITH THE BALANCE IN
FAVOR DECISION IT WORKS.
VERY WELL WHEN WE HAVE RATE
CASES FOR EXAMPLE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A UTILITY ASKING FOR MONEY
AND THEN YOU HELP REPAIR
ADVOCATES WHO PUSH BACK ON
UTILITIES AND DEVELOP A RECORD
THAT THEN YOU CAN EVALUATE THE
COME UP WITH THE BALANCED.
DECISION IT WORKS FAIRLY WELL IN
THE RENEWABLE SPACE WE YOU HOW
OF ELVES.
A VERY ORGANIZED INTEREST GROUPS
AROUND SOLAR AROUND ENERGY
STORAGE ABOUT MICHAEL GRADES
WOULD DO A GOOD JOB ADVOCATING
FOR THEIR ALL POINT ENVY
ENVIRONMENTAL L. AGENCIES THAT
DOESN'T EXIST IN THE IN THE AREA
OF OF SAFETY OF WILDFIRES THAT
SAFETY IN PARTICULAR.
SO WHEN WE HAVE A WELFARE
MITIGATION PLANS AND OPEN THE
PRECEDING WHAT OVER THIRTY
PARTIES WHO JOINS THIS PROCESS
BUT WHEN WE'RE ORGANIZING THE
WORKSHOPS I PULLED THE PARTIES
TO SAY HEY WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS
ON VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
ON CONDUCTORS.
ELEMENT AND ON A COUPLE OF OTHER
ITEMS BUT DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
FROM THE PARTY'S SCORE HOW
EXPERTISE IN ANY OF THESE AREAS
WHO COULD PARTICIPATES IN THE
WORKSHOPS IN A MEANINGFUL
DIALOGUE WITH THE UTILITY AND
WHEN GETTING YOUR BODY.
ALL THIS IS A IT THINK ONE
PERSON THAT'S SORT OF PASSED THE
L. THAT SO.
QUESTION -- HOME BUT IT'S THAT
JUST GOES TO SHOW THERE WAS A
LOT OF INTEREST GROUPS ALL.
AGAINST THE SOLAR AND OTHER IT
TYPICAL INTERVENOR IS BUT THEY
DON'T HAVE EXPERIENCE IN THE
SPACE SO WE REALLY LACK THE
RECORD THAT WE TYPICALLY WOULD
HOP IN OTHER TYPE OF POLICY
MATTERS.
THAT THE THAT IS INFORMATIVE.
AND NOT IN THAT SENSE.
ALL MY YOU IT WITH SEE IT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING FOR
BEST PRACTICES AND WE EIGHT
THINK HALL ENOUGH.
TO EVALUATE THAT THE UTILITIES
OR DOING THE RIGHT KINDS OF
THINGS THAT WE WOULD BE
EXPECTING THEM TO DO.
ALL UNITS YOU LOOK AT THE PLANS
THE ROLE FAIRLY SIMILAR IN TERMS
ALL THE KINDS OF PROGRAMS THAT
UTILITIES HOW I THINK YOU HEARD
THAT FROM THEIR PRESENTATIONS --
THEY DIFFER IN TERMS OF WHERE
THEY ARE THEY'RE STARTING POINTS
IN TERMS OF THEIR PIECE OF THIS
SCALE NOW ALL WE'RE THEY'RE
PUTTING SOME OF THE EMPHASIS.
ELM.
BUT THEY ALL HAVE VERY SIMILAR
ELEMENTS OF BUILDING BLOCKS.
AND ELM THE COMMISSION MOSTLY
EVALUATED THE HOME FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH SB NINE A ONE
THE BILL THAT ESTABLISH THIS
PROCESS THE OUTLINE NINETEEN
SPECIFIC CRITERIA THAT THOSE
PLANS.
IT'S A HOUSE BILL WHICH THE L.
PROPOSED DECISION THEN STOPS
EVALUATION PROPOSES THAT THE
DUDE CUTS THAT COVERED THE THE
NINETEEN ITEMS THAT THE WAS
SUPPOSED TO COVER.
AND THE MAIN.
HELP QUEENS ELM THAT THE
PROPOSAL THAT'S THAT'S CURRENTLY
OUT IS RAISING.
IS THE ISSUE OF METRICS AND
EVALUATING EFFECTIVENESS OF
THESE MEASURES THE SB NINE OH
ONE REQUIRED UTILITIES TO
INCLUDES PERFORMANCE
MEASUREMENTS AS PART OF THEIR
FILINGS WITH ALL OF THE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES THE UTILITY
SUBMITTED.
WERE.
FOCUSED ON THE PIECE OF
DEPLOYMENT HOME IT WOULDN'T HAVE
ANY WEATHER STATIONS THE DOING
HOW YOU KNOW HOW MUCH VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT THE DOING HOW MANY
MILES OF OF LINES THE REPLACING.
A LOT LOTS COMMUTING TO ANY
SPECIFIC RESULTS WILL OF THOSE
ACTIVITY IS.
AND ELEMENT IN THE SOTHE COULD
ONE OF THE THINGS THE COMMISSION
THE SAYINGS OF FOR US TO OVER
TIME TO EVEN BEGIN TO BE.
A BE ABLE TO MAKE BETTER
DECISIONS AROUND THIS WE NEED TO
START PLAYING THESE PROGRAMS TO
PERFORMANCE AND ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
COVERED TO CONDUCT THERE IS AND
ACTUALLY HOW THE DATA BEHIND IT
TO HOW MANY IGNITIONS AS AN
EXAMPLE -- THEY REDUCE
[inaudible]
AND IT SAID THAT THAT THAT'S ONE
AREA HOME AS THE NEXT STEPS THE
COMMISSION -- WOULD BE VOTING TO
ADOPT OF THOSE PLANS.
AND THEN L..
WE WE REALLY WOULD BE STARTING
THE PROCESS ALL.
THEM PLANNING FOR THE NEXT ROUND
YOU KNOW I THINK I'LL AND WITH
THE COVERING THIS QUESTION ALL
OF THE P. YOU SEE CAPABILITIES
IN EVALUATING THESE KINDS OF
PLANS AND EVALUATION OF DO THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND YEAH I THINK WE HELL OF A
LOT OF ROOM TO GROW IN THIS
SPACE I MEAN THIS FIRST ROUND WE
DID WITH NO ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
ARE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL FOR
HAS BEEN NINE OH ONE IS STILL IN.
THE BEING CONSIDERED -- SO WE
DID SOME REASSIGNMENTS BUT IT'S
YOU KNOW WHERE WE WEREN'T SET UP
TO BE EXPERTS IN THE US OUR
STAFF ARE GENERALISTS WHO WE
HIRE OUT OF MASTER'S PROGRAMS
WITH JUNE WITH ENGINEERING
DEGREES AND YEAH AND THE NO THIS
IS.
A SPACE WHERE.
PEOPLE HAVE ENTIRE CAREERS
DEDICATED JUST.
ONE SPECIFIC ASPECT OF IT AND
WHEN YOU HAVE UTILITIES
PREPARING THEIR PLANS THE HEALTH
EXPERTS IN METEOROLOGISTS AND
FIRE WEATHER EXPERTS AND EXPERTS
WERE ARBORISTS AND YOU KNOW
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE IS
WRITTEN BY.
THEIR TOP EXPERTS IN THIS FIELD
SO IT IS GENERALLY AGAIN YOU SEE
ISN'T SET UP TO TO TOP THE
EXPERTISE OF UTILITY THAT'S JUST
NOT HOW OUR PROCESS WORKS.
SO YOU THINK THAT'S A GAP.
OF I'VE BE A HOLLOW PROPOSAL IS
PART OF THE ME REVISE RIGHT NOW
OF HOW I THINK WE CAN THE DRESS
SETS WHICH IS BY IN THE SHORT
TERM HIRING MORE CONSULTANTS TO
WORK.
HOME FOR THE P. YOU SEE OUT SO
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY WILL
COMMENCE ALL THE RECORD AND BE
ABLE.
TO FULLY ELM.
HELP EXPERTS AS PART OF OUR TEAM
WHO CAN ASK DEEPER QUESTIONS IN
EACH OF THOSE SUBJECT AT OUT OF
AREAS.
ALL MAY THINK WE ALSO LACKEY ELM.
THE VISION OF WHERE ARE WE GOING
WITH ALL OF THE S. THRE'S A LOT
OF ACTIVITY THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED AS THE PART OF WELFARE
MITIGATION PLANS.
IN THE GROUP LOOKS LIKE THE
RIGHT TYPE OF ACTIVITY BUT WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE AN ARTICULATED
VISION OF WHAT GOALS WERE TRYING
TO HIT.
L. IN THE FUTURE.
AND YOU KNOW WE HEAR A LOT OF
YOU KNOW STATEMENTS ALL OF THIS
IS GOING TO TAKE A LONG TIME WE
SHOULDN'T EXPECT THAT THIS FIRST
ROUND THE WELFARE MITIGATION
PLANS IN THESE EFFORTS THE
UTILITIES ARE PUTTING A PLACE
RIGHT NOW.
WILL ADDRESS ALL WILD FIRE
PROBLEMS THIS YEAR THIS WILDFIRE.
SEASON THE THAT WERE DONE
ANYTHING THIS GENERALLY
RECOGNITION DIGITAL LEVEL OF
COMPLEXITY OF THIS PROBLEM WE
CAN EXPECT A SIMPLE SOLUTION.
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO UNPACK
THIS A BIT MORE AND GET MORE
SPECIFIC WHAT DOES THIS MEAN HOW
LONG OF A ROAD MAP WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SO WE TALKING ABOUT BEING
ABLE TO SEE MEASURABLE RESULTS.
IN FIVE YEARS OF THREE YEARS AND
TEN YEARS IN FIFTY YEARS LIKE
WAR AND AND HOW WE GOING.
TO TRACK THAT AND WHAT DOES THAT
SYSTEM OF THE FUTURE LOOK LIKE
IS IT SOMETHING THAT'S MORE
RELIANCE ON THE ON MICRO GRIDS.
AND ELHAM.
UNDER GROUNDING OR IS IT COVERED
CONDUCTORS WHAT'S THE ROLE OF
WHAT THE MONITORING AND HOLLER
ALL THESE PIECES GOING TO COME
TOGETHER AND WHERE ARE WE GOING.
SO AGAIN RIGHT NOW THAT DOES NOT
EXIST AND I THINK THAT'S A GAP
THAT NEEDS TO BE FILLED.
WELCOME AND IN TERMS ALL OF
COMPLIANCE ELM YOU KNOW I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE ON THAT FRONT AS WELL.
ALL IS SPECIALLY A THING IN AS
WE KIND OF WORK ON LARGER ISSUES
THE WAY RIGHT NOW FACING.
ALL OF REALLY ARTICULATING OF
THE ROLE OF THE PLANS BECAUSE
TYPICALLY WHEN YOU DOING
COMPLIANCE AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES.
YOU WANT TO AND FOR US TO
REGULATION TO A STANDARD THAT'S
BLACK AND WHITE.
ALL MY PLANS GENERALLY PLAY AT
THE FRONT OF THE ROLE -- HOME
AND I THINK KIND OF FIGURING OUT
THE BALANCE OF BLACK AND WHITE
REGULATIONS THAT SET THE FLOOR
THAT WE EXPECT THE 100%
COMPLIANCE WITH THE VERSES THE
ROLE OF THE PLANS.
THAT -- MORE TO QUEUE LEADING
THE PACE OF DEPLOYMENT OF
CERTAIN PSYCHOLOGIES OR
ACTIVITIES OF UTILITIES AND
KINDA HOW YOU RECONCILE THOSE
THINGS.
ELM AND WHAT WE REALLY WANT TO
BE WANDERING PERFORMANCE TO AND
WHAT FOR ELM I THINK A LOT OF
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS THAT --
HOLLAND'S B. AND L. FULLY
ANSWERED YES IN THE WORKING OF
LARGER REGULATORY SCHEME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON MY NAME IS DANIEL
WERE LANTA ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH CAL FIRE --
OVERSEEING -- MANY OF OUR FIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS -- INCLUDING --
UTILITY MITIGATION -- THE FOCUS
OF MY TESTIMONY TODAY WILL BE ON
CALPERS INVOLVEMENT IN REVIEWING
THE PLANS -- BUT I DO WANT TO
JUST STAYED AT THE AT THE
BEGINNING HERE THAT I WON'T BE
SPEAKING DIRECTLY ON A SPECIFIC
ELEMENTS OF EACH INDIVIDUAL
PLANS -- AS I DON'T HAVE DIRECT
KNOWLEDGE ON THE SPECIFIC
CONTENT -- SINCE OUR COMMENTS --
THEY'RE STILL BEING OFFERED TO
THE C. P. YOU SEE IN OUR PART OF
THEIR THE COMMISSION'S ONGOING
DELIVERED A PROCESS -- BUT IT'S
A FOR IMPORTANT UP TO EMPHASIZE
AT THE OUTSET HERE THAT ADOPTING
TO WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA'S DRY
MEDITERRANEAN CLIMATE OUT REALLY
REQUIRES A SYSTEMATIC APPROACH --
THAT MEANS IN ADDITION TO
FOCUSING ON PREVENTING UTILITY
BECAUSE WILDFIRES.
WE ALSO HAVE TO INCLUDE PLANS ON
MAKING SURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE HARDENED AGAINST WILDFIRES
THAT THEY IF YOU'LL BREAK IN AND
AROUND -- NEIGHBORHOODS WE HAVE
TO ENSURE THAT COMMUNITIES HAVE
PROPER EVACUATION ROUTES WATER
SUPPLIES -- FIRE PROTECTION
RESOURCES -- WE'VE TO BUILD
HOMES OUT OF AMBER RESISTANT
BUILDING MATERIALS WHILE
MAINTAINING A HUNDRED FEET A
DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
BY REMOVING DEAD AN OVERGROWN
VEGETATION.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO UNDERTAKE
LARGE SCALE PROJECTS THAT RETURN
OUR FORCE IN OUR WILD LANDS --
BACK TO THEIR HEALTHY STATE AND
OF COURSE WE NEED TO EDUCATE THE
PUBLIC -- TO PREVENT THE START
OF HUMAN CAUSED WILDFIRES SO
THIS IS REALLY A AT AN ALL
INCLUSIVE -- APPROACH NOW A
LARGE PORTION OF CAL FIRES
MISSION IS TO WORK TOWARDS
PREVENTING WILDFIRES -- FROM
OCCURRING IN THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS -- OBVIOUSLY WE'VE SEEN A
TREND OF LARGER DAMAGING
WILDFIRES -- THAT EVEN BECAUSE
BY UTILITY OWNED A POWER LINES
IN INFRASTRUCTURE.
ANALYZING THE PAST FIVE YEARS OF
OF FIRE DATA -- UTILITIES PARK
WILDFIRES MAKE UP ABOUT 9% OF
THE OVERALL WILDFIRES WITHIN OUR
JURISDICTION OVER THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA.
HOWEVER THESE FIRES CONSTITUTE
ABOUT 21% OF THE OVERALL ACRES --
THAT ARE BURNED AND SO TYPICALLY
WHAT WE FIND IN THESE TYPES OF
FIRES IS THAT THEY ARE COUPLED
WITH SIGNIFICANT WEATHER EVENTS --
THAT FANNED THE FLAMES AND ALLOW
THE FIRES TO GROW -- VERY
QUICKLY AND VERY SIGNIFICANTLY.
IN RECENT YEARS OUT WE FOCUS --
TO IN SUPPORTING OUR STATEWIDE
EFFORTS TO REDUCE UTILITIES PARK
WILDFIRES -- QUITE HEAVILY NOW
THREE YEARS AGO FOLLOWING THE
PASSAGE OF SB AT TEN TWENTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR HILL -- WHICH
REQUIRED THE CHILI MITIGATION --
PLANS -- TO BE FORMED -- CAL
FIRE BEGAN ITS PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION -- IN PROVIDING OUR
WILDFIRE EXPERTISE -- IN THE
CREATION OF THE PLAN TEMPLATE.
THE FOLLOWING YEAR -- WE WORK
WITH THE C. P. YOU SEE AND WE
PUT TOGETHER A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING -- TO SHARE
RESOURCES KNOWLEDGE -- AND BEST
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE DEVELOPING A STRATEGY
THAT WAS A CONSISTENT APPROACH
AMONGST.
THE AGENCIES IN ORDER TO PREVENT
THESE TYPES OF FIRES.
NOW THIS MAY SOUND ROUTINE --
BUT OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS I WOULD SAY THAT THAT THIS
WORK AND THIS COLLABORATION I
HAS BEEN CRITICAL.
CAL FIRE BRINGS TO THE TABLE
HERE EXPERTISE IN WILD FIRE
SUPPRESSION WE HAVE EXT.
A LOT OF EXPERIENCE IN
PREVENTING THESE TYPES OF FIRES
AND SO THAT'S WHAT ARE WHAT WE
BRING TO THE REVIEW TEAM BUT
I'LL JUST SPEAK FOR MY COLLEAGUE
HERE THE CPUC.
THEY BRING A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF KNOWLEDGE RELATED TO CHILE
INFRASTRUCTURE UTILITY
OPERATIONS REGULATION IN
ENGINEERING THESE ARE NOT
NECESSARILY -- ITEMS THAT WE
HAVE AS AN AGENCY SO WORKING
TOGETHER WORKING COLLABORATIVELY.WE WE CREATE A STRONG TEAM --
THAT CAN TACKLE THESE ISSUES --
AND AND SPECIFICALLY THESE
ISSUES CRITICAL TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO THE WALL FOR MITIGATION PLANS --
AS I MENTIONED ARE AN OVERALL
PART OF OUR OUR OVERALL UTILITY
BECAUSE WILDFIRE PREVENTION
EFFORTS -- AMONG OTHER THINGS IN
THE PLANS -- WE ANALYZED WHERE
ENHANCED VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
IS NEEDED TO PREVENT CONTACT
BETWEEN VEGETATION LIVE WIRES --
WE LOOKED AT WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES
THE POWER -- SHOULD BE SHUT OFF
TEMPORARILY TO PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY -- WHERE UTILITY SYSTEMS --
SHOULD BE HARDENED AGAINST
EXTREME WEATHER AND OTHER
THREATS -- THREE USING THINGS
LIKE COVERED CONDUCTORS AND FOR
I RESISTED PULL MATERIALS LIKE
YOU HEARD EARLIER AND WHERE AND
WHEN OVERHEAD POWER LINES SHOULD
BE RELOCATED UNDERGROUND.
COMING BACK TO IT TOO TO SEE IF
YOU SEE OUR INCREASE PARTNERSHIP
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS --
HAS ALREADY COMMITTED A PART
TIME I IN FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
COMMISSION TO REVIEW EIGHT OF
THE WHILE FAR MITIGATION PLANS
THAT HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED.
NOW OUR ROLE AS DIRECTED IN LAST
YEAR'S SB NINE A ONE BY SENATOR
DODD -- WAS TO CONSULT WITH THE
C. P. U. C. AND TO BRING OUR
EXPERTISE AS I MENTIONED TO BEAR
DURING THEIR REVIEW PROCESS.
OUT OF THE NINETEEN REQUIRED
ITEMS IN EACH PLAN SEVEN OF
THOSE SPECIFICALLY INCLUDE
WILDFIRE RELATED ITEMS.
THOSE -- ITEMS INCLUDE WILDFIRE
RISK AND RISK DRIVERS ASSOCIATED
WITH TYPOGRAPHY AND CLIMATE --
UTILITY PLANTS FOR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT -- AND PREVENTATIVE
STRATEGIES TO MINIMIZE THE RISK
OF LINES AND EQUIPMENT CAUSING
CATASTROPHIC FIRE SO THESE SEVEN
ELEMENTS REALLY WERE OUR FOCUS --
WE BROUGHT -- WITHIN OUR OWN
AGENCY SPECIALIST AND FIRE
RESPONSE FIRE BEHAVIOR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WILDFIRE
PLANNING.
FIRE PREVENTION ENFORCEMENT AND
COLLECTIVELY -- THESE --
EMPLOYEES SPENT HUNDREDS OF
HOURS REVIEWING THESE PLANS.
NOW WHAT OUR SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS -- WHO REVIEWED AND
COMMENTED UPON -- THAT THAT
INFORMATION WAS THEN --
INCORPORATED INTO THE CPU SEES
PROGRAM STAFF DEVELOPMENT OF
THEIR PROPOSED GUIDANCE TO THE
COMMISSION SO IT'S IMPORTANT
NOTE THAT THAT IN OUR REVIEWING
OF THESE PLANS WITH CHEAP YOU
SEE WE REALLY ACTED AS A
TECHNICAL ADVISOR TO THEM.
OF THE COMMISSION OBVIOUSLY
MAKES THE FINAL DETERMINATION ON
WHAT COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
OUGHT TO BE INCORPORATED OR
REFLECTED -- IN THE FINAL PLAN.
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
ASKED EARLIER IN AND KIND OF I
THINK ONE OF THE IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS IS YOU KNOW WHAT WE DO
WITH ENFORCEMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PLAN.
AND WHILE THAT IS A FUNCTION OF
THE THE C. P. U. C..
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK SIDE BY
SIDE WITH THE C. P. YOU SEE --
YOU KNOW BRING IN OUR EXPERTISE
TO ASSIST IN MEETING THE
OVERARCHING GOAL AND AND REALLY
THE UNIFIED GOAL OF REDUCING
UTILITIES PARK WILDFIRES.
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN AN INCREASE
IN COMMUNICATION NOT JUST AMONG
START TO AGENCIES BUT BETWEEN
OTHER STATE AGENCIES AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY -- BETWEEN US AND
THE UTILITIES.
ANOTHER REPORT EDITION TO THESE
PLANS THAT WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING IS AN
INCREASED SHARING OF DATA.
AS WAS MENTIONED THERE'S A LOT
OF DATA THAT THE UTILITIES ARE
COLLECTING AND WE WANT TO SEE
HOW WE CAN ACCESS THAT DATA USE
THAT DATA.
AND SHARE OUR DATA AS WELL --
FOR EXAMPLE -- LEVERAGING THE
FUEL TREATMENTS PERFORMED BY
UTILITIES -- IS IN A POOR ONE TO
US WHEN AS WE LOOK AT WHERE WE
PUT IN FUEL BREAKS IN AND AROUND
COMMUNITIES WE WANT TO FIND WAYS
WHERE WE CAN KIND OF
COMPLEMENTARY -- TAKE THESE
PROJECTS AND AND COORDINATE TO
REALLY MAXIMIZE -- THE OVERALL
EFFORT.
SO AS I CONCLUDE I I JUST WANT
TO STRESS AGAIN THERE IS NO
SINGLE SILVER BULLET -- WILDFIRE
MITIGATION ACTIVITY -- INCLUDING
INDEPENDENTLY STOP CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES FROM OCCURRING IN
CALIFORNIA -- WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO OBVIOUSLY MAKE
STRIDES AT REDUCING UTILITIES
PARK WILDFIRES -- BUT WE REALLY
HAVE TO CONTINUE KIND OF THIS
HOLISTIC APPROACH THE ALL OF THE
ABOVE -- STRATEGY IN PROTECTING
OUR NATURAL ENVIRONMENT AND OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM WILDFIRES AND
THE THOSE EFFORTS INCLUDE AS I
MENTIONED FUEL REDUCTION AROUND
COMMUNITY ENFORCING DEFENSIBLE
SPACE.
PLANNING COMMUNITIES THAT A
RESILIENCE -- FOR WILDFIRES --
IT RESTORING OUR FORCE LANDS
BACK TO THEIR NATURAL HABITAT.
AND IN LISTING THE PUBLIC AS A
PARTNER -- THROUGH EDUCATION SO
IT REALLY HAS TO BE THIS ALL OF
THE ABOVE APPROACH.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
TO LOOK FOR TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ROSS BROWN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'LL TRY TO
KEEP MY COMMENTS PRETTY BRIEF
HERE -- I THINK WHAT I'D LIKE TO
DO IS JUST FOCUS IN ON A COUPLE
OF THE PIECES THAT ARE IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR THIS YEAR I
KNOW THIS ISN'T I BUDGET
COMMITTEE HEARING BUT I THINK
THEY'RE GONNA PROVIDE IMPORTANT
INSIGHT TO A LOT OF THE
QUESTIONS YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT.
JUST CAPACITY FOR THE STATE TO
OVERSEE AND EVALUATE THE WILD
FIRE MITIGATION PLANS AND KIND
OF HIGHLIGHT.
SOME OF THE THE KEY GAPS AND AND
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE AT LEAST IN THE NEAR TERM --
SO -- THERE'S A VARIETY OF
POSITIONS WERE AT P. YOU SEE FOR
SERVER VIEWING THAT WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS BUT I DO WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT.
A TWO PIECES THAT ARE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S NAY REVISION PROPOSAL
ONE AS A AS THE MS MALASHENKO
MENTIONED -- THERE'S SOME
CONTRACTING FUNDS ONE IS TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
CONTRACTS ONE TIME TO HIRE
ESSENTIALLY CONSULTANTS.
OR EXCUSE THIRD PARTIES FOR MORE
KIND OF BOOT BOOTS ON THE GROUND
INSPECTION AND MONITORING.
OF THE FUTILITY EQUIPMENT --
THIS IS -- NOT TYPICALLY -- THE
WORK THAT YOU SEE HAS DONE SO
FAR AND SO I THINK THIS IS KIND
OF A GOOD EXAMPLE THE HIGHLIGHTS
KIND OF YOU KNOW WHAT.
BUT NOT IN A STATE REGULATORS
ARE CURRENTLY DOING -- BUT
THEY'RE THEY'RE REQUESTING
RESOURCES ON JUST A ONE TIME
BASIS TO HIRE -- SOME THIRD
PARTY TO AT TO HELP GET THAT
WORK STARTED WITH THE VISION OF
THE SB NINE OH ONE ESTABLISHED A
PROCESS WHERE THE UTILITIES
WOULD -- CONTRACT WITH THIRD
PARTIES THEMSELVES TO DO SOME OF
THAT -- AUDITING INSPECTION WORK --
AND I MEAN IN OUR VIEW THE THE
RIVER THE REQUEST IS REASONABLE --
BUT IT AGAIN IT KIND OF
HIGHLIGHTS A GAP THAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
WHAT'S A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
FROM THE LEGISLATURE'S
PERSPECTIVE.
IS TO MAKE SURE THE FOR THAT --
TEMPORARY FUNDING THAT THE STATE
IS GETTING GOOD INFORMATION
ABOUT.
HOW THAT PROCESS IS INFORMING IN
WHAT WORKS WHAT DOESN'T WORK YOU
KNOW HOW THAT WOULD INFORM KIND
OF FUTURE DECISIONS AND FUTURE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OF THAT TYPE
MONITORING?
OF THE SECOND PIECE AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER IS --
ADDITIONAL CONTRACTING FUNDS
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CONSULTANTS.
TO HELP GUIDE THE WILDFIRE --
POLICY FUNDING IS THINKING
THROUGH -- SOME OF THESE
EVALUATION METRICS THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED AND SNOW WHEN
ABOUT WHEN OF VALUE IN THE
STATE'S EVALUATING WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLANS -- WHAT?
YOU KNOW WHAT TOOLS ARE WHAT
METRICS ARE GONNA KIND OF
PROVIDE THE BEST INFORMATION ON
WHETHER THE OUTCOMES THAT THE
STATE IS EXPECTING ARE ACTUALLY
BEING ACHIEVED -- YOU KNOW HOW
ARE UTILITIES DECIDING ON WHICH
MITIGATION MATT MEASURES ARE
DOING THE MOST.
TO REDUCE THE MAXIMUM Là RISK
PER DOLLAR SPENT ON SO AGAIN WE
THINK YOU KNOW THAT THIS REQUEST
FOR RESOURCES AGAIN IT WAS WHICH
IS ONE TIME IS.
REASONABLE BUT AGAIN IT IT
REALLY KIND OF HIGHLIGHTS.
YOU KNOW WHERE WHERE WE ARE AS A
STATE AND KIND OF YOU KNOW OUR
OUR NEED TO KIND OF BE THOUGHT
TO PASS THE IN TRYING TO THINK
ABOUT THESE ISSUES AS A PC
MENTION THERE'S NOT.
AND A CLEAR PLAY BOOK ON YOU
KNOW HOW WE'RE GOING TO REVIEW
THESE AND EVALUATE THESE AND
MEASURE THE OUTCOMES FROM A LOT
OF THESE ACTIVITIES GOING
FORWARD AND SO THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK THAT.
THE STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE ON
THAT FRONT -- I DO WANT TO JUST
BRIEFLY JUST MENTION REAL QUICK
COMING WE WE'VE DONE A THE
INITIAL REVIEW OF THE OTHER WILD
FIRE MITIGATION PLANS -- THE
PROPOSED PC DECISIONS IN OUR
VIEW YOU KNOW ONE OF THAT THE
KEY CRITICAL QUESTIONS IT AGAIN
AS OUR OUR DECISIONS BEING MADE
ABOUT WHICH OF THESE MITIGATION
ACTIVITIES ARE REALLY.
DOING -- DOING THE MOST TO
REDUCE RISK WORK WE GET KIND OF
THE BIGGEST BANG FOR FOR THE
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE SPENDING ON
REDUCING THAT RISK.
AND HOW ARE WE MEASURING THOSE
OUTCOMES ARE WE LOOKING AT AT
SOME OF THAT THE OUTCOMES THAT.
RELATED TO ACTUAL RISK REDUCTION
OR ARE WE LOOKING MORE AT JUST
IN PUTS INTO THE PROCESS FOR
EXAMPLE YOU KNOW TREES TREND
RATHER THAN.
YOU KNOW AT A REDUCTION IN THE
NATION'S OUR OVERALL RISK AND SO
A LOT OF THESE BITS THESE ISSUES
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED SO
FAR OF THE PC AS YOU HEARD IS
VERY WELL.
AWARE I THINK OF A LOT OF THESE
CHALLENGES AND GAPS AND NEEDS TO
KIND OF IMPROVE THE OVERSIGHT
PROCESS BUT WE JUST WANNA.
KINDA PROVIDE OUR OUR COMMENTS
INITIAL THOUGHTS ON ON HOW THE
PROCESS IS ROLLING OUT SO FAR AS
WELL AS YOU KNOW WHERE SOME OF
THE BUDGET REQUEST THAT INTO
SOME THAT CONVERSATION SO HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT I I THINK THAT DO YOU.
ALL THREE OF SERVE HIGHLIGHTED
AGAIN THE CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE
ALL.
TIRED OF DEALING WITH RIGHT NOW
AND CERTAINLY THE SPELL CHECK OR
YOURS.
TALKING ABOUT THE FUTURE AND THE
ROAD MAP AND HOW WE GET ARE WE
ASKING ALL THE RIGHT QUESTIONS
RIGHT NOW.
AND I GUESS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT.
IS ON THE TABLE AND CERTAINLY WE
KNOW THAT THE NINE A ONE
COMMISSION MAY AND CERTAINLY THE
GOVERNOR STRIKE TEAM HAS HAD
SOME REFERENCE -- TO THE
REGULATORY CHANGES AND AND AND
WHAT MIGHT BE A NEW STRUCTURE
THAT WE MIGHT ENTERTAIN OF TO
GIVE A DIFFERENT KIND OF FOCUS
TO SAFETY.
AND CERTAINLY YOU HAVE BROUGHT
TO A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF INSIDE
AND WE RECOGNIZE TO YOUR
TESTIMONY ENTER OUR REPORT TODAY
THAT -- YOU KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE
THESE HEARINGS AND IT'S HARD TO
GET -- TESTIMONY FROM EXPERTS TO
COME IN AND HELP AND GIVE YOU
INPUT AND DIRECTION -- THAT
MEANS THAT WE'RE SORT OF IN
UNCHARTED WATERS AND THERE IS
STILL SORT OF AN UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW.
WE'RE TO MOVE FORWARD -- AGAIN
FROM THE REPORT -- LOOKING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THERE'S NO
OTHER STATE IN THE NATION THAT'S
DEALING WITH.
THE THE NATURE OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES AND ITS IMPACT AND ON
THE UTILITY -- INDUSTRY AND AND
THE HARDWARE IN THE EFFORT
STRUCTURE THAT THE UTILITIES
LINES MAKE BECAUSE IN THESE
WILDFIRES IN AUSTRALIA IS
PROBABLY THE ONLY PLACE I GUESS
THAT COMES CLOSE TO WHERE WE CAN
AT LEAST -- GET SOME TYPE OF
COMPARISONS.
AS SO WE ARE.
IN A NEW PLACE AND WE'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD AND I THINK THAT.
THE CPUC AND AND AND CERTAINLY
IN YOUR LEADERSHIP ON ON SAFETY
RELATED MEASURES HAS BEEN -- YOU
KNOW VERY EFFECTIVE BUT WE NOW
HAVE TO DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
HA.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHETHER THE
CPUC IS THAT PLACE GOING FORWARD
OR IF WE NEED TO HOW DO WE LOOK
AT A BECAUSE CREATING SOME NEW
STRUCTURE HOW DOES IT CONTINUE
TO INTERFACE APPROPRIATELY WITH.
CAL FIRE -- JUST A YOUR THOUGHTS.
THEY SEE CURRENTLY TWO MAIN --
GAPS IN THE IN THE CURRENT SIXTY
CAN OF PARADIGM BUT WE HAVE SO
THE FIRST GAP WAS IN THE POLICY
MAKING ASPECT OF IT.
TELL ME IS THAT WE ARE IN A
REACTIVE MODE WE FOR THE SYSTEM
WHERE WE HAVING UTILITIES COME
UP WITH WELFARE MEDICATION PLANS
AND THEN THE SUBMIT THEM WHEN WE
REACT TO THEM RIGHT WHEN NOT
DRIVING THE BUSES THE STATE.
NOTED START DRIVING THE BUS AND
ACTUALLY DEVELOP THE PLAN IN THE
VALUATION FRAMEWORK AND FILLED
THE GAPS THAT CURRENTLY EXIST
WITH THERE'S NO REAL REGULATION
FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S NO.
STANDARD RIGHT NOW THAT SAYS
WHAT WELL WHAT THE HARDENING
USUALLY INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION LOOKS LIKE
DELAYS HAVE OPINIONS ON AT
COVERED CONDUCTOR INCREASING
SPACING BETWEEN CONDUCT THERE'S
A TO TREAT SUCH AS WELL WOULD TO
STILL PULL REPLACEMENT.
BUT THERE IS NO STANDARD LIKE IF
YOU LIKE YOU HAVE AN BUILDING
CODES RIGHT OF THE THAT THAT
ACTUALLY EXISTS RIGHT IN ORDER
TO DEVELOP THAT.
THAT SEEKS RESOURCES IN THIS IS
ALL VERY HIGH LEVEL.
OF EXPERTISE THAT'S REQUIRED.
HOME THERE ARE VERY FEW PEOPLE
OUT THERE.
ALL MY WHO HOW OF BOTH EXPERTISE
AND WILD FIRE AND UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE SAME TIME.
ALL.
GLOBALLY VERY FEW OF THEM AND
THEY'RE OR OLD IN HIGH DEMAND
AND WORKING SOMEWHERE.
AND TO BUILD THAT LEVEL OF
EXPERTISE THAT SEEKS PHENOMENAL
AMOUNT OF TIME SO WHETHER IT'S
THE P. YOU SEE OR ANY OTHER
AGENCY IN CALIFORNIA OR ANYBODY
ELSE WHO DOES IT THIS WORK IS
GOING TO BE DIFFICULT AND YOU
NEED.
TO PAY PEOPLE.
WHO HALL OF ALL OF IT PLEASE
VERY STRONG ANALYTICAL SKILLS
AND THE LEAST SOME OF THE
EXPERTISE TO BE ABLE TO KIND OF
NAVIGATE THE SPACE?
SO WELL -- AGAIN I'M SORRY I
DON'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT YOU BUT
BUT HOW ARE YOUR ANALYTICAL
SKILLS.
I'M JUST SO YOU KNOW WE NEED WE
NEED A LOT OF PEOPLE ON AS WE
PUT YOU IN THE POINT IS WOEFULLY
HELLO SO WHETHER IT'S A P. YOU
SEE OR ITS ANY OTHER AGENCY I
THANK THE WORK NEEDS TO GET DONE --
ALL MIX IT IN THE SAME THING SO
THE SECOND GAP IS SORT OF THOSE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND
THE PC PROGRAM WAS ALWAYS
DEVELOPED FILM THE TO DO OLD.
AUDITS SO AND INVESTIGATIONS OF
INCIDENTS ELM IT WAS NEVER TO DO
INSPECTIONS AT SCALE OF UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE GROUND --
THAT KEY CAPABILITIES IS IS NOT
EXISTENCE -- SO.
ON THE RAIL SIDE WE ACTUALLY
HAVE MORE OF A FIELD PRESENCE
WHERE WE ARE INSPECTORS WALKED
TRACK ELEMENT AND DO THAT KIND
OF ON THE GROUND IT'LL IT'LL
INSPECTION WITH EVERY MILE OF
TRACKING IN CALIFORNIA.
IS INSPECTED BY THE BY THE STATE
PROGRAM SO WE HELP OF FORTY
PEOPLE [inaudible] FOR OF FOUR
THOUSAND MILES TRACK I DON'T
HAVE THE NUMBERS IN FRONT OF ME
BUT IN ORDER TO JUST BE ON PAR
WITH THE LEVEL OF INSPECTION
THAT WE DO WHAT RAIL.
IT'S ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED
THIRTEEN HUNDRED FIFTEEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE AND IT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE WILLIAM DOLLAR
BUDGETS IT JUST BECAUSE OF THE
LEVEL OF EXPERTISE AGAIN PLUS
THE LABOR SHORTAGES THAT WE'RE
HAVING.
RATE SO AGAIN TO ME THE QUESTION
HERE IS AN STE.
BUT YOU KNOW WHICH AGENCY DOES
IT'S ALL MY BUT THAT THIS GAP
EXISTS AND WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
IT.
SO SO.
YOU KNOW THE THE TWO VIA SO
CONTRACTING RESOURCES IN THE MAY
REVISE A THING CALLED IN THE
SHORT TERM.
AT LEAST GET STARTED AND START
GETTING MORE DATA I THINK WITH
THE POLICY ASPECT YOU KNOW CAN
BE DEFINITELY.
HELP WE CAN MAKE A LOT OF
PROGRESS IN THE THREE YEAR TIME
FRAME TO FILL THOSE GAPS.
I THINK AS FAR AS INSPECTIONS ON
THE GROUND A A THING THAT SEE
HERE REAL.
HELLO A LONG COMPLICATED DEBATE
AS TO THE YOU KNOW THE ROLE THAT
WE WANT TO PLAY AS THE STATE'S
OVERSIGHT OF UTILITIES.
AND HOW TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
AND HOW MUCH OF OF THIS.
SORT OF IN PHYSICAL INSPECTION
OF INFRASTRUCTURE WE WANT TO BE
DOING THE STATE'S EMPLOYEES OR
WITH THIRD PARTIES OR CONTINUING
RELYING.
ON UTILITIES TO DO THAT WORK AND
MORE ACTING THROUGH A STRICT
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS WHEN THEY'RE
NOT DOING WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE DOING [inaudible]
SO.
FIRST OF ALL. 21% OF THE ACREAGE
IS SEEN IS CAUSED BY AN
ELECTRICAL LINES.
YET IT SEEMS LIKE WE'VE HAD A
BAD RUN OF LUCK FOR THE
UTILITIES IT SEEMS LIKE MOST OF
THE DAMAGING FIRES.
HAVE COME FROM THE UTILITIES
PERHAPS IS JUST AROUND OF LOCKER
PERHAPS IS TO CHANGE BECAUSE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE THERE'S DIFFERENT
CONDITIONS.
FEWER ELECTRICAL STORMS -- MORE --
MORE HIGH WINDS AND PERHAPS IT'S
ALSO HARDER -- TO CONTAIN THE
FIRES AGAIN BECAUSE OF GLOBAL
WARMING IN PARTICULAR YOU DON'T
GET DO AT NIGHT ANYMORE BECAUSE
THE NIGHTS WARM UP MORE THAN
THAT DAY.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY WERE
LOOKING AT THE MOST IMPORTANT
FACTOR OR MISSING THE 80% -- BUT
TO THE EXTENT THAT OVER TIME YOU --
TALKING TO CAL FIRE YOU HAVE
INSIDE IN THAT.
THAT THERE ARE OTHER THINGS WE
NEED TO LOOK AT I WOULD HOPE YOU
WOULD GET BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
WELL IF I COULD JUST ADD TO THAT
YOU ARE CORRECT CHANGING CLIMATE
ABSOLUTELY HAS A HUGE ROLE IN
WHAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS WITH THE
SEVERITY OF WILDFIRES.
GET IF YOU JUST COMPARE THE THE
THE IT'S ALMOST DOUBLE THE
AMOUNT OF ACRES TO THE
PERCENTAGE OF NUMBER FIRES AND
OFTEN THAT'S AS I MENTIONED
BECAUSE YOU HAVE WERE WE SEE
THAT THESE -- UTILI SPARK FIRES
OCCURRING WHEN THERE'S EXTREME
WINDS NON SO IT CHANGES CLIMATE
IS IS OBVIOUSLY A COMPONENT BUT
I WOULD ALSO ADD THAT -- YOU
KNOW THE CONDITION OF OUR
FORESTS PLAYS A HUGE ROLE OF ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY WHY IN SANTA
ROSA IN THE THE TUBS FIRE OR
EVEN GO LOOK AT THE CAMPFIRE.
THE FACT THAT WE HAD A FIRE WITH
SUCH INTENSITY THAT WAS ABLE TO
BURN SO QUICKLY WAS NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF EXTREME WIND WHICH
WAS A FACTOR.
BUT ALSO THE FACT THAT THE
VEGETATION IS SO OVERGROWN AND
THEN YOU ALLOW IT -- AFTER YEARS
OF DROUGHT TO DRY OUT -- FIRES
CAN RACE UP TO A COMMUNITY MUCH
QUICKER AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT I REALLY STRESSED
AND WE WE CONTINUE PUT A LOT OF
FOCUS IN ON THESE FUEL REDUCTION
PROJECTS SO THAT -- YOU KNOW EAT
WHEN THESE FIRES DO OCCUR
BECAUSE THE THE TRUTH IS.
FIRE THAT IS ALWAYS BEEN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WELL BEFORE US WE ARE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO PREVENT
EVERY SINGLE FIRE AND SO WE HAVE
TO PREPARE -- BUT I WOULD STRESS
AGAIN CHANGING CLIMATE JUST MAKE
THAT MORE DIFFICULT -- BUT AN
OVERGROWN FORCED ON A HEALTHY
FOREST -- ALLOWS THE INTENSITY
OF THE FIRES THAT TO BECOME MUCH
MORE CHALLENGING FOR US TO FIGHT
YEAH.
I'M ALSO VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
WHERE WE HAVE HOUSING.
A PARADISE WAS KNOWN TO BE IT IS
AFTER WAITING TO HAPPEN SINCE
THE EIGHTIES BECAUSE IT IS AN
AREA WITH.
THAT TECH GETS EXTREME WINDS ARE
AND ALSO THAT IT DIDN'T HAVE ACT
ADEQUATE TO EXITS AND IN FACT.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
CITY ACTUALLY NARROWED SOME
STREETS BECAUSE THEY WERE
WORRIED ABOUT PEDESTRIAN SAFETY.
AND THAT BECAUSE SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS AS WELL THEN PEOPLE
WOULD GET CAUGHT IN A CUL DE SAC
AND NOT BE ABLE TO GET OUT SO.
MANY PROBLEMS THERE I WISH THERE
WERE A WAY WE COULD RELOCATE
PARADISE [inaudible]
THAT TIME.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THE WAY TO DO
THAT.
AT ANY RATE SO -- MS MALASHENKO.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
ABOUT REACTING [inaudible]
AND WHAT I ASKED THE UTILITY
REPRESENTATIVES WAS -- CAN YOU
TELL US WHAT'S MOST COST
EFFECTIVE AND IT ONLY HAS TO
AVOID WONDER TWO FIRES A DECADE.
AND IF IF FOR EXAMPLE UNDER
GROUNDING I AGREE IS MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE NOT ONLY IN.
THE CAPITAL TO DO WHAT THAT IN
THE MAINTENANCE.
BUT IF IN THE COURSE OF YOUR
HIRING THESE EXPERTS AND
CONSULTANTS YOU COULD TRY TO TRY
TO GO -- DO SOME WORK TO
DETERMINE WHAT IS THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE IT MAY NOT BE THE
CHEAPEST THING TO DO RIGHT NOW.
IT MAY VERY IN THE LONG RUN.
AND I HOPE YOU CAN DO THAT ALSO
THE QUESTION ABOUT THAT WE GOT
FROM MISTER MERRETT SU CHI.
DOES THE P. YOU SEE HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DO THAT THE ANSWER
IS CLEARLY.
YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE THE RIGHT
PEOPLE AND THAT'S UNDERSTANDABLE
BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T HAD THAT
BEFORE -- SO AGAIN I DO TH AND
ALSO WE HAVE THE PRESIDENT A P.
YOU SEE TALKING ABOUT THE PLACE
WHERE WE REALLY.
HAVE THE RESOURCES WE NEED IS ON
RARE FOR HOSTS.
OF THAT THAT'S THAT'S THE PLACE
THAT THEY HAVE TREMENDOUS
EXPERTISE AN INSPECTION IN OTHER
AREAS -- NOT IN PARTICULAR IN
TRUCKS AND ALL OF THAT SO -- I'M
HOPING THAT WE CAN FIND THEY ARE
MOST A COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO DO
THIS AND YOU DON'T JUST DON'T
HAVE TO REACT. TO THE THE
UTILITIES PLANTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELL WE DO APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
MOMENT AND TURN TO THE PUBLIC --
AND SEE IF WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS PANEL BUT ALSO
IT REFLECTING ON ANY OF THE
PARTS OF THE PRESENTATION FROM
THE EARLIER PANEL SO IF THERE'S
ANYONE FROM THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS.
THE COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME
YOU'LL BE RECOGNIZED.
SEEING NONE WE JUST REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE WE
KNOW WE'RE SORT OF RIGHT AT THAT --
AT THE DOORSTEP OF SOMETHING
THAT'S REQUIRED US TO USE OUR
STRETCH AND TO CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT NEW INNOVATIVE WAYS TO
ADDRESS THIS CHALLENGE IN FRONT
OF US IN THE KNOW THAT THESE
YEAR AGENCIES ARE.
WORKING TOGETHER EITHER THROUGH
THE FUNDING OR COOPERATIVE
RELATIONSHIPS -- THAT CERTAINLY
HELPS AND WE'VE TAKEN A LOT OF
NOTES BASED ON YOUR PRESENTATION
TODAY SO IT'S OPENED UP OUR
THINKING.
TO SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE ASK I THINK DOCTOR
QUIRK IS.
CONTINUES TO THROW THE
SUGGESTION OUT THERE IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT
YOU BELIEVE AT THIS POINT
REQUIRES A LEGISLATIVE ADDRESS
THEN IT'S CERTAINLY -- WE'RE
OPEN TO HEARING THAT AND TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN BEST
RESPOND.
BUT FOR TODAY THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED